[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the petty Yeti does not know arithmetic
at all I mean like we have evidence
she don't she doesn't know that there's
only 330 million people in the United
States she doesn't know that she doesn't
know that there's only 8 billion in the
world so like the majority of people in
the world cross the border is that what
she's saying 6 billion
surely she's surely she meant million
right even then but she
laughs
oh stupid ass oh Marge just doesn't math
at all
a petty Eddie does not match but this is
not surprising
that this is who represents the
Republican party as leadership
I mean she's not officially leadership
but she might as well be she leads their
messaging she's back on Fox news she's
back with Tucker Carlson
talking about a national divorce I hope
she keeps saying this [__] even Laura
ingraham's like when she shut the [__]
up Lori Ingram had Matt Getz on
and that you know rapey mcforhead that
guy and um he was defending Madge Marge
the petty Yeti Marjorie Taylor hoof foot
green he was defending her
the sentiment of a national divorce
um everyone knows what that means
it means means you want a civil war
and just like the last Civil War it's
it's about the freedom of black people
it's it's what it is I mean we watched a
video the other day where Marjorie
Taylor green was complaining about how
white men just have it the worst they're
they're the most depressed demographic
in this country white men the [__] out
of here with that nonsense
that's what she's saying when she wants
a national divorce she wants white
States
and black States not red and blue that
ain't that it that's not what the [__]
she's saying that's not what they mean
wipes white supremacy does not afford
assimilation of of races and commingling
with Races they it wants full
segregation
that's what the whole when they tell
someone a person of color go back where
you came from well you go back where you
came from you white cracker
do you have any idea who was here first
it was brown people you dumb
[__]
We Are The Intruders
the colonizers yeah I said it
you go back where you came from Marge
actually that might be the foothills of
California
since she's a yeti in a Yeti a Bigfoot
I don't know do big do Bigfoot they
gotta have five toes right
not three
I know maybe she isn't a Yeti I don't
know
um
[__] her either way [__] her
but this idea
that having Republicans in charge of
anything is a good idea is the dumbest
great idea they've ever had
when Marjorie Taylor green is talking
about six billion people do you know how
many people is six billion with a
[__] B billion that's a big ass
number like that's a huge [__] number
it's a lot that's a lot that's a lot of
[__]
a lot of them holy [__]
and she's just like yeah they walked
across the border I thought Trump built
a [__] wall didn't he didn't he hey
can someone check didn't he build a
[__] wall that was supposed to solve
that problem
I mean they built it he went to the
borders like look at my beautiful wall
then he'd make America great again with
his wall how did six billion people
cross it while Joe Biden's president
I don't know these are just questions
that you might ask that dumb
[__]
she seems to have great answers to
stupid [__] questions
we should start asking her these
questions I don't know just just a
thought
I mean she ain't got any good thoughts
so
it's Friday it's bonehead of the week
can you guess who won
can you guess who won bonehead of the
week oh my God Jesus [__] Christ it
never fails
we tried to do bonehead of the week
where you have like new people to pick
from nope nah nope Marjorie Taylor green
comes to the top of the Heap Donald
Trump figures that a way to do six
bone-headed things in a few [__] days
every every [__] time
I don't know what to tell you I I would
love to keep these [__] idiots off
the bonehead of the week list
I would like to move on to some new
characters on bonehead of the week I I
don't make the rules though
I don't make the rules
I don't I don't get I don't get to tell
Trump that he can't grift his supporters
and make money off his stupid [__]
photo op in Ohio why mayor Pete is
actually doing work on the ground
wearing a [__] hard hat standing next
to the goddamn tankers that derailed and
released all the chemicals toxic
chemicals standing right next to those
[__]
and
and Donald Trump goes to McDonald's to
sign manga hats where he makes money
signing Maga hats
and he buys them all Big Macs with their
money
he literally he used campaign funds to
buy McDonald's for everybody he used
their money to buy McDonald's for him
think about it
and then the Trump water thing oh my God
everyone keeps saying that water is 13
years old that water is not 13 years old
he grifted all that water he made all
them years ago he grifted off that
already
this is new white labeled water I'm
telling you he white labels this water
all over the [__] country with his
[__] toxic properties that he's got
but leaked toxic chemicals into our
Earth just because it has the name Trump
on it
he white labels water that's what he
does and he probably has an LLC
and I don't know maybe it's
um called Nazi Springs LLC
yeah
it's a German company [__] I don't know
any uh any white labels water with the
name Trump on it so he can sell it to
himself so he can make money
and he can sell it to his campaign
oh baby yeah I bet every [__]
campaign event has Trump water at it
every time he gets on an airplane in the
campaign's foreign paying for something
he probably he probably expenses
a whole pallet of trump water for that
trip just for the people on the plane
this is the same white labeled [__] that
you get at Walmart
the same [__] it's the same water it's
just and and we watched the video
yesterday of of Rambo Sylvester Stallone
who is a great friend of Donald Trump by
the way
oh he's a fantastic that he loves him he
says it in the video
he says he wouldn't wash his [__]
socks in Trump water
I mean he didn't know it was Trump water
but he's like I wouldn't wash my [__]
socks in this [__] this stuff is nasty
not surprising I mean it's probably it's
probably from a tap somewhere literally
they're just they're just filling up
water bottles putting on the Trump label
it's just dog [__] in a bottle like the
rest of the [__] that Trump does there
was a video though
of a few kids and this is oh my God they
called Democrats groomers and [__] and
all that all this nonsense there's a
[__] video of a reporter questioning
a few children
in Ohio these Palestine Stein whatever
the [__] it is in Ohio listen hey uh
they're giving uh Joy Behar [__] online
for saying that it's Ohio's fault I said
it first it is Ohio's fault the the
people who voted Republican in Ohio this
is your problem you did this to this
town and most the people in the town I
think 75 percent of them or some [__]
voted for Trump it's your fault you did
this and then when the the person who
did it to you came to sign hats and
throw [__] bottles of poison at you
labeled Trump water you were like Yay
these children I don't know they're
probably I don't know fifth sixth
graders and I don't know I can't really
tell in the video what grade they're in
but the reporters asking about the water
fountains at the school that the school
has the water fountains open baby oh why
not well they're not scared of germs at
all why why are these people bitching in
the first place aren't they supposed to
be immune to this stuff by now aren't
these Trump supporters supposed to be
the the tough sons of [__]
who who drink out of the dog [__] creek
so they can get them germs so they can
have them some immunity
these are the ones that aren't afraid of
covered they want to get covered yeah
that's the best way to be immune
what are you scared of you [__]
[__] go drink the water
go go grow your vegetables in the soil
why are you scared you bunch of [__]
ass [__] you're scared of some toxic
chemicals God damn are you scared of
viruses too
you bunch of [__] huh
you you Trump supporters out there
anyways they're questioning these
children about the [__] water
fountains in the school all the while
these kids literally have Trump Flags
draped over them
it's a cult [__] it's a cult
they have Trump Flags draped over them
and these kids are talking about how
they won't drink out of the water
fountains there's a lot of kids that do
but they won't drink out of them but
they got the Trump flag and the reason
why is because oh man there's poison
coming out of that water fountain
Donald Trump made sure of that by
deregulating toxic chemicals train cars
and their braking systems oh it's
fantastic oh and not only that he didn't
pass any infrastructure he just [__]
talked about it the entire time he was
President he just talked about passing
infrastructure
you [__] bunch of boneheads
[__] Matt Walsh Matt Walsh you
know this you know this [__] creep
ass [__] that's always talking
about children's genitalia oh he gets in
he he gets in on the train derailment
he's commenting on train derailments now
yeah
so um President Biden several days ago
now this is from February 13th I just
saw this I just I just saw that
have seen Saul I don't give a [__] I'm a
hillbilly Matt Walsh Matt Walsh was
saying
trained derailments around the country
toxic human chemicals pouring into the
water supply enemy aircraft patrolling
the skies inflation driving mirrors and
Power about climb plaguing our cities
Matt Walsh is really concerned about
environmental issues because President
Biden made concert tickets more
affordable he regulated them
hey Matt
hey Matt you stupid [__]
it is regulations that will hold
companies like Norfolk Southern
accountable
not just when an accident happens but
preventing
such toxic fumes pouring all over our
environment destroying communities you
piece of [__]
listen if you're out there [__]
blaming mayor Pete or Joe Biden Or
democrats
for this [__] spill you are you are
playing into the Nazis hands
if you're on my side the left side oh
yeah Tony don't be knocking tyt
they're on our side they're not on our
side when they say stupid [__] like that
everyone knows why this happened this is
not [__] rocket science folks Norfolk
Southern
is going to do its damnedest to to milk
every single drop of profit out of every
single rail car that they move along
those tracks they're not going to give
money to [__] rebuild the tracks
they're not going to use their money to
rebuild braking systems to make it safer
so chemical spills don't happen they're
not gonna do it
unless we force them to We the People
and I find it hilarious
I find it hilarious
that people who are on board with
Marjorie Taylor green who think six
billion people walked across the border
over Trump's Great Wall which is in
impenetrable apparently
and will make America great again don't
we all remember that [__]
are the same [__] who are now
environmentalist
because because there's a bunch of trump
supporters somewhere in Ohio who voted
for this they voted for the spill they
voted for the spill you voted for it
and the only reason why anyone is
pointing it out is because it happened
in a town where the majority of people
voted for Trump and they're still
draping the kids that are groomed
to love the [__] the to Love Lies are
draping Trump Flags over themselves
when he is the one they voted for him to
do this to them
he had a big ceremony where he cut the
cut the [__] ribbon and said we're
gonna go back to the 1960s on regulation
that's what we're gonna do across the
board
it's handcuffing corporations in their
profits
I get tired of hearing
at the left
is trying to get in your lives and
trying to destroy your lives and trying
to get up all up in your business
that they're groomers and somehow
they're obsessed with children
this one clip one clip of these kids
and and these Trump Flags aren't like
tattered these are brand new Flags
these are brand new Flags because guess
what happened when Trump Went to went
went to Ohio guess what happened
a bunch of [__] grifting ass merch
Trump merch stands popped up
so not only are these people in economic
strife
they went to [__] be succubus on them
to make profit off Trump merch because
Trump was there
and he wasn't even there there he just
went there to go to McDonald's and shake
a few people's hands far away far away
from where the spill was yeah that
[__] [__] ass [__] wasn't
gonna go anywhere near those toxic
chemicals where they spilled [__] no
hell no he wasn't gonna go there
that would require him to put on a hard
hat and actually look like he knew what
the [__] he was doing
like mayor Pete
go down in there with the people who are
working in the cleanup the EPA and the
FEDS who have been there from the very
[__] beginning another [__] line
that they keep telling
foreign
because of Republicans and deregulation
of industry in this country so that they
can milk more profit
that they don't pay tax on
that ends up in the one percent
bank account not our bank account that
GDP isn't shared with us
that's their GDP goddammit
it's Republicans
who dumped that toxic chemical in Ohio
and it's not just Ohio they're dumping
toxic chemicals all over the country
they don't give a [__] Jesus Christ the
first year Joe Biden was President one
of the first 18 months
you remember
Joe Biden oh he's raising gasoline
prices he won't open up the Keystone XL
pipeline
and the reason why is because they don't
want it to leak
toxic sludge
into our land
that's the whole [__] reason why
that that that additional pipeline does
not stop in our country it doesn't
benefit our country it benefits Canada
[__] them [__] them they can keep their
[__] oil sludge we don't want it in
our ground
and the reason why it would leak in our
ground is because there's not tight
enough regulations for those pipelines
to go across the sacred land the
indigenous land that it was going to go
across [__] them it ain't worth it
it ain't worth the profit that's what
Joe Biden said and they blame gas prices
for a pipeline that didn't exist
remember this they were they're
clamoring to dump toxic sludge on
indigenous land but oh buddy oh buddy
their deregulation of environmental and
toxic chemicals and train cars from
spills dumps in a town that's 70 75
Trump supporters by God you better watch
out they're gonna be they're gonna be
Tree Huggers in a minute Matt walls JD
Vance Trump and the like
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
I bet I would bet if this continues
I would bet that the Republican that
real America First Nazi party are going
to be for climate change but only only
in this little town in Ohio
outside that little town in Ohio oh it's
a fraud but in that town oh yeah yeah
there's that toxic chemical definitely
affected the climate in that town
[__] boneheads man [__] boneheads
you gotta stop voting Republican and the
other thing you got to stop doing is is
[__] making up stupid [__] and
playing into the Nazis hands you gotta
stop you gotta stop
you have to quit this stuff yesterday
um Pete Buda judge did the right thing
and he said you know what I did wait too
long to address this he said we
addressed it on a governmental level but
I didn't address it publicly and I
shouldn't have waited so long he
admitted he admitted he did something
wrong oh my God holy [__] who would who
would have think that a public official
would apologize for not doing the thing
that he probably should have done
but again I say over and over and over
again if the president United States and
people to judge the Secretary of
Transportation had to show up at every
goddamn spill of toxic chemicals in this
country that's all they would be doing
that's all they would be doing and it's
because Republicans absolutely do not
want to regulate these [__]
they do not want to protect you they do
not want to protect your communities
they only want to protect the profits of
Corporations and corporations are going
to spend a hell of a lot of money to
make sure those profits are huge
oh but Tony oh but Tony they Lobby
Democrats and I'm tired of that [__]
let's stop stop it
these regulations were passed under
President Obama a Democrat [__]
and you can damn well better be sure
that that now
now at this point especially with the
politics
that Joe Biden this Administration is
going to clamp down on these
[__]
and I would bet that we're going to see
a report next year coming into the
election of how many not toxic chemical
spills that we've had
since they took action Democrats
not Republicans because if it was
Republican Administration they would
blame it on Hillary Clinton or Hunter
Biden's laptop and then deregulate a
little more they'd be like well it's
probably because it's probably because
those corporations in Norfolk Southern
just are hamstring by regulations that's
probably why there was a toxic spill we
need to deregulate make sure Norfolk
Southern can do whatever the [__] they
want for however much they want forget
the communities you can damn well better
bet that that's what Trump did that's
that's that's what he did
Edwards toxic chemical spills going on
over a country when he deregulated the
[__] why do you think the
Democrats put the regulations in the
first place
it's hard enough in our democracy to get
anything done preventing prevention oh
[__]
that's a [__]
welcome to Friday
Friday you guys gonna have a good
weekend I hope you have a great weekend
you know you should do this weekend you
should come watch the Sunday rant on
patreon I do I do a special rant every
single Sunday on patreon it's outside
the show this show will always be free
you always be able to watch this show
free you can watch it on for free
on YouTube so you can subscribe for free
on YouTube
you can watch it you can watch it on
Twitter
you can download it for free on Apple
Spotify Google you can watch it on
Facebook
at the Tony Michaels just follow us on
Facebook you can also watch it for free
on Twitch it's free over there you can
if you log in with your Amazon Prime
account on Twitch you can subscribe to
us and you get one free subscription
free there's all kinds of free ways to
watch two hours every single day but on
Sundays I do a special rant I'm not sure
exactly the subject matter that I'm
going to cover this weekend I usually
try to pick something
the last few weeks that um I just can't
get to there's so there's so many of
these [__] boneheads and there's a
video of a bunch of [__] Nazis down
in Florida I believe with bullhorns
yelling and screaming anti-semitic
things
and of course they're Nazis at some
Jewish people in cars and it's [__]
Wild video it's wild stuff like people
like oh there's no there's no
anti-Semitism in this there's no Nazis
yeah they're in Florida
um Rhonda Santos is letting them Harbor
there I mean Jesus Christ he's doing
what Nazi Germany did with books back in
the 1930s he's doing that in Florida as
we speak
I I guess I guess there's a proposal
going around where they can search
children's backpacks without parents
permission for books that are banned
oh my God holy [__] you listen listen
there's a bill in Tennessee
where they're trying to detransition
is the word
transgender youth
they want to de-transition them they're
taking consent away from parents I told
you they would do this I told you I said
this is their way to take parental
consent away from you that is what they
want because if they take your parental
consent away now they own the children
you know when they say save the children
that's the it's the opposite they don't
want they don't want anything to do with
saving children
Jesus Christ we watched a video
yesterday from some [__] some [__]
oath keeper that's a representative in
Alaska who's been censored twice by his
party say out loud into a microphone in
a [__] public hearing that he's glad
that children of physical violence die
he's happy because it doesn't cost that
much money and you know what then those
kids don't exist anymore
they want to take away consent from you
from your children yeah okay it starts
with the books
it starts with the books and the gender
talk because they're obsessed with
genitalia they're obsessed with
children's genitalia and they're
obsessed with the books that children
are trying to use to read obsessed with
it obsessed
but their goal is to take away
everyone's consent
everyone's consent from their children
don't you [__] doubt me just do it I
don't you know you can do it [__] you
want I'm telling you go read I mean if
they haven't banned it in your state yet
go read the history books on Nazi
Germany in the 1930s and 1940s and see
what Hitler's strategy was with the
Hitler Youth just go look at it
go look at it and then and then come
back and tell me I'm full of [__]
let's do that
just do that just do that
maybe that's what I'll talk about more
this weekend on the patreon on Sundays
with Tony I I don't know there's a few
names for it we're gonna have to name a
lot of these segments you know what I
mean we got the [__] list Roundup we got
bone end of the week uh shoot this [__]
we're having fun with that I think we
might do um
more shoot the [__] during the week two
or three times a week we'll do [__] to
[__]
Tuesdays we have Paul Fridays we have
bonehead of the week so maybe like
Monday Tuesday or Monday Wednesday we'll
do more shoot the [__] uh where you ask
questions in the chat so but if you want
you can go over to patreon check out my
patreon page the tonymichaels.com you
can click on the patreon link or go to
patreon.com D Tony Michaels that is how
I stay in front of this microphone for
free how I stay in front of this
microphone for free is I make a living
doing this and you get extra content
over on patreon the other way is the
twitch thing if you log in with your
Prime account you can also go to store
not the Tony michaels.com check out all
the merch there
speaking of Ron DeSantis here's a Rhonda
Santos can go [__] himself shirt uh you
can find those at store not the Tony
michaels.com that's
store.the20michaels.com or you can just
go to thetonymichaels.com and all the
links are there and that is the best way
to support not just not just with
monetary value because if you want to do
that that's great and I appreciate it
but the main thing is is getting the
word out sharing this episode sharing
prior episodes sharing new episodes
liking stuff on social media liking this
video right now if you're on YouTube and
you haven't liked this video like the
son of a [__]
that's free that's easy support and it
spreads the word through the algorithm
sometimes I don't know the algorithm
hates me I think it's because I say the
word [__] too much but you guys like how
I curse so I can't stop I just can't
quit and we're not gonna quit today
today's Friday top of the hour bonehead
of the week we'll be right back I gotta
show you some clips before we go to the
bone of the week stick around we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
Moon
is this your favorite segment or what
it's one of mine
I love bonehead of the week did you know
we used to do bone in the week on the
weekends yeah it used to be a weekend
thing
and before we did episodes every single
day I used to do the show on Wednesdays
and we did it on Wednesdays and when we
did I did a one hour I think my very
first episode of any episodes one's like
30 minutes long
Brent what episode are we at today Jesus
Christ I mean 339 goddamn
that's a lot of talking
339 episodes of Tony that's a lot of
Tony God damn uh no we got three and
I've been on every single one of them
never took a break off any of them even
when I lost my voice a couple times 339.
don't give two [__]
or a voice if you ain't got one you
still gotta talk you still gotta do it
you got to do the work you got to get
out there you gotta be consistent and
it's how you were gonna beat back
these Nazis
that's how it's going to happen that's
how it's going to work
now let's see I'm gonna to um give you a
a glimpse here at the best
uh I'm not gonna do do the shitless
music because and we're gonna run out of
time here we always go over on Fridays
we need to keep that under control I
know you guys want three hours I want to
do three hours too
like really I want to do this show three
hours every single day
I think I actually believe that we still
won't have enough time
we'll get to three hours in Amanda
should be like four hours
because Amanda's always in the always in
the chat going three hours three hours
three hours yeah [__]
we'll get the we'll get the three hours
in Amanda like four hours four hours
four hours is she here today I I don't
see him yeah Amanda's here
she knows what I'm talking about
um but I would love to do the show for
three hours a day but I gotta justify it
because again it's my job like this is
what I do now I don't make a lot of
money doing it yet I mean maybe I will
because you guys are the best audience
in the world and you've showed me so
much support like really honestly it
it's been overwhelming I think we're at
um almost 320 members on the patreon
page excuse me 120. geez
um I love that 320. it's like uh
Chris is saying 24 hours easy damn 24
hours when the hell would I sleep eat or
take a [__] God damn 24 hours a day you
literally you could I got enough
episodes now Chris you could watch 24
hours a day and not run out there's 339
of these [__] you just go from
339 and just start backwards and there's
a few on YouTube that are banned like
YouTube has banned several my episodes
and her [__] [__] ass [__] what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
someone reported them for some [__] I've
gotten some of them put back up but some
of them are still banned maybe I should
hey that's a good idea I should put some
of the Band episodes on patreon and then
you guys can see why you thought they
were banned because YouTube doesn't tell
me
literally when they when they when they
send me a little thing they're like hey
we [__] deleted your video
you know they sent me a little message
like we turned it off [__] and and they
don't tell me why I mean they tell they
give me the reason why
like the the the terms of service thing
that I broke
but the the thing is is that they don't
tell me where they're not like oh at
this point in the episode
you [__] said this and that's what we
don't like
so when they when they do that when they
when they delete one of my episodes
they're like this is the one we deleted
this is it this is the episode and this
is why now you have to go find it
so I'm like are you [__] serious I go
listen to two hours of this episode and
figure out what you don't like that I
said do you have any idea how
inflammatory I'm trying to be in the
first place
Jesus Christ and I've got to figure out
why you're a bunch of [__] snowflakes
and why this video was important get the
[__] out of here that's why I'm not
monetized on YouTube I probably never
will be
literally and not monetized on YouTube
they turned it off a long time ago I
can't get them to turn it back on I've
appealed and they won't do it
and again it's because of my mouth but
that's the whole [__] purpose like
that's the whole point right and
eventually I probably lose my YouTube
account I mean it's possible or at least
for some period of time I've been banned
I've had a couple times where I've
banned for seven days for
um actually posting on YouTube suspended
I guess you call it
but
you know it is what it is what are you
going to do yeah I can't stop not I
can't not be [__] real and raw with
these goddamn real America First Nazis
and we we can't we can't [__] like
glove this [__] and I've had people
personally call me and tell me hey if
you just tone down your rhetoric you
tone down your language you could get
syndicated on National radio and then so
many more people could hear you I'm like
yeah but they're not going to hear the
right message they're not going to hear
exactly what they need to hear rather
they [__] like it or not
so what's I mean yeah what what I want
to do with this show is I want to do
three hours every day and say [__] that
no one can ignore the truth the [__]
real raw truth without a bunch of facts
without a bunch of [__]
loads of [__] data and tables and
polls and all this [__] that you have to
thumb through that they do on NPR and
MSNBC and all this [__] [__] that
[__] you know the truth you know the
truth you don't need to be hampered by a
bunch of data and fact Checkers and all
this [__] it's really simple the
majority of Americans don't want
the government in their [__] love
life they do not want the government
taking away the consent of parents they
don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill they want to have a decent
[__] wage so they can afford housing
and food
and a lifestyle that affords them I
don't know a vacation every once in a
while for them to retire at some point
it's not complicated [__] to understand
it really isn't and you don't need and
and I showed you on patreon that's
that's what we did last Sunday on
patreon as I talked about being the the
antifa rushland ball the left there's a
group out there a research group that
researches podcast
and they put mine at the extreme left
which is hilarious
oh my this would piss this would piss
Democratic socialists off that I was I
was deemed extreme left
that's hilarious and that I didn't I
didn't give any kind of uh data or or
polls or any kind of information backing
up what I was saying the reason why is
because I don't need I don't need to
give you a [__] lesson and an
encyclopedia and a whole stack of data
to back up what you know is true it's
not complicated we got enough [__]
money in this country to make sure our
citizens aren't [__] screwed by
corporations and screwed by the
Republican party it's an it's enough of
this stuff
but who am I to say right who am I to
say
what people want so 24 hours it's a
little it's a little over the top Chris
but everyone wants three hours here
four hours is good someone says
um
yeah I know
I know listen this two hours a day
um is easier and easier for me and it
gets easier for me when you guys uh come
every single day to listen because you
are the best audience in the world I
mean we had some [__] here we got
our [__] here we got I got people
that are on the left that hate me
because I knock tyt or I don't say the
exact [__] they want me to say and it
pisses them off and they get all butt
hurt in the [__] chat I don't care
who they are you know you get all upset
I don't give a [__]
I don't and I piss off the trolls the
right-wing trolls and the right wing
trolls stay man and they watch the whole
[__] show
the whole thing front to back Chris in
has been here since the very beginning
when there's like 10 people watching and
Chris n is still here two hours every
[__] day and he watches it from the
back every single day I know you're out
there lurking Chris in I see you you
gotta be there
yeah
but that's I mean that's what I'm trying
to do for you
is give you a microphone because I've
only got one microphone for our
democracy only one now a lot of people
listen
and more and more gonna listen over the
next year
I want to make this into the I'm I
really seriously my goal is to make this
one of the most powerful shows for
messaging a narrative for the
pro-democracy coalition
and I am not scared to call it
pro-democracy propaganda I'm not scared
to call it that [__] them it'll piss
them off it'll get them to listen
because that's the key that is the key
to get people to listen why do you think
why do you think these people in in
Ohio where Trump shirt showed up
have their kids draped in Trump blags
and they're they're excited to get
autographs in a McDonald's on a Maga hat
and get Trump water thrown at them
while he does nothing doesn't go
anywhere near the crash site doesn't
have any kind of any kind of substance
as far as helping on the ground with
officials nothing because he can't
because he's just some fat slob from
Florida
he has no power none
other than to make a photo op and make
these people think he's Jesus or
something
whoosh but that's what I want to do is I
want to piss those people off I want to
piss people off in Ohio that I'm saying
it's your fault
it's your fault this spill happened I
want them to come listen
and they should I I think I think that
tens of the hundreds of thousands of
people should listen this show every
goddamn day every single [__] minute
of it
and get pissed off rather they're pissed
off at me or just pissed off at what I'm
talking about they should get pissed off
they should
and here's a perfect example of getting
pissed off about what you should be
pissed off about this is the best Rudy
Giuliani clip I've ever seen in my life
there's some good there's some good
clips of Rudy Giuliani
listen there's some really good clips of
Rudy Giuliani getting heckled been
calling a Nazi and a traitor but this
one oh my God this one is it is [__]
beautiful best goddamn Rudy kaluti
Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
clip I have ever seen in my life watch
this [__]
[Applause]
you're a [__] Trader
oh the sweet sweet sounds of the word
[__] right am I right am I right or am I
right oh my God the sweet sounds of the
word [__]
you [__] piece of [__] you [__]
traitor there's a lot of context in this
clip
um the biggest kind
um context is this is New York City now
here's Rudy Giuliani here you can see
him here Rock walking with the police
officer and and some other folks
do you know that Rudy Giuliani used to
be the mayor of New York City do you
remember who was the mayor during 9 11.
it was Rudy Giuliani he was America's
mayor remember
oh New York City love that [__]
man they wanted him to be mayor again
but he was termed out at that point
and now when he goes to New York City
this is the introduction that he gets
you're a [__] traitor because he is
he's a [__] traitor
and the indictments are coming oh God
damn I I would imagine Rudy's one of the
ones that are flipping like a
[__] but Jay says a disgrace
yeah that's exactly it the thing they're
pissed off the most about in New York is
this guy used to be one of them he used
to be for them and he runs around the
country talking about how bad New York
is and the people there are just a bunch
of liberals and blah blah blah blah blah
he [__] turned his back on the
American people
just just like these people in Ohio who
crowded around Trump with their Trump
flags and getting their [__] hat sign
and the water thrown at him mark my
words mark my words in 15 years they're
gonna hate that [__]
they're gonna hate that [__]
with the passion
and he'll be lucky to be dead in 15
years Trump he'll be lucky
because then he won't have to see how
much his [__] support has turned on
him
all the truth the truth is a
[__] man
the truth is a [__] and when the
truth finally comes around to bite you
in the ass it's a [__]
it's a sumb [__]
I mean it hurts much much more than lies
will ever damage you the truth will
absolutely bury you
and it's coming for him it's [__]
coming for him just like the truth Has
Come For Rudy Giuliani
in this clip right ear
the dude you're a [__] traitor used
to be loved in New York City I mean Rudy
Giuliani would have went to New York
City and be like Oh America's mayor Oh
yay Rudy Giuliani
he even ran for president off the back
of that [__] he didn't win because he's
a [__] bonehead
but this is what happens when the truth
catches you and bites you in the ass
[__] Rudy Giuliani by the way [__] him
[__] him but that's the best clip I've
ever seen oh my God that's the best
Giuliani clip I've ever seen I want to
thank um
Amanda here and I want you guys to go
follow her she made some art this
morning and I really like it
and she says happy Friday wanted to add
a little spice because I love your show
thank you Gabe and and Texas Paul so
she's giving shout out this is the art
that she made so thank you I I I think
it's I think it's great that she put the
effort in so I want you guys to go
follow
Amanda here it's at simply unders
underscore Savage 85. Oh follow Amanda I
retweeted this as well so if you're on
Twitter go give her a follow and that
was that was really nice of you this
morning it made my morning to be quite
honest with you made my morning so we'll
follow Amanda just give her a little
shout out there okay
let's see what else do we have
um Gabe Sanchez is finishing up the
bonehead of the
bonehead of the week Graphics here
so I want to start that soon at the top
of the hour
can you guess who won
oh can you guess he won let's see who
does he have
let me I don't want to play any videos
that I had to play twice uh
I got a couple videos here uh to show
you actually you know what I want to
show you this one here is and this is on
Sean Hannity Show last night
um
this is a
let's see
he's saying and he's telling me who the
uh the other ones are okay okay that's
good now I know what I can do I know
what I can pull off here this is on Sean
Hannity's show last night that um I I
believe this lady's name is Jessica
she's on the the fox's uh five or
whatever the [__] it's called the one
that Jesse Waters that scumbag
um he hosts uh but here she's giving
pushback because fox is in it fox is in
a really shitty position about the lies
they've been telling about this
derailment Sean Annie's been pushing for
weeks that that Barack Obama's the one
who took the regulations off of toxic
train cars it's not true
did
it's not not true it's just not
it was Obama to put the regulations on
toxic train cars
so the the thing is is that he's been
lying about it for weeks
and yesterday I think I believe
yesterday the day before
uh boxing friends had to run a clip
where they were like no actually those
regulations were taken off in 2017 by
Trump like they had to finally tell the
truth and the reason why is because this
Dominion uh lawsuits really got him in a
pinch because they've been lying
blatantly unopenly especially they're
they're commentating host in the
evenings but here is um Jessica pushing
back on Sean handy on this idea that
somehow Trump put the regulations on
which is not true and that Obama dropped
the regulations it's just not [__]
true fundamentally it's not true that
that Democrats would give a [__] less
about the safety of communities than
Republicans it's just not true that's
not the [__] truth Republicans care
way more about about company the one
percent getting profit than the
communities that they that they hurt to
get that profit but let's listen treat
every voter dignity and respect it's not
your fault whatever
District you live in if something like
this happens you wouldn't say to the
people who live in Flint Michigan that
it's their fault that they ended up with
bad water because they voted for
Democrats
um and I think that the point would be a
lot better taken and I think there's
validity to that point is we know now
about the regulations that were rolled
back in 2017 we've seen the beginnings
of the report from the NTSB we do know
that there were federal agents officials
on the ground at the beginning of this
yes secretary Pete was late to get there
but that doesn't mean that the
government had abandoned them they
wouldn't even declare it a national
disaster but governor dewine and
Congressman Johnson I believe that's his
name both said that they had gotten
everything that they had asked for and
that they didn't need anything else this
wasn't about a dereliction of Duty on
the part of the Biden Administration it
it really wasn't Tammy I treat every
voter with dignity and respect it's not
your fault whatever
and there it is there it is uh Sean
Hannity ran smack dead in front of the
truth
on his show
and it's bound to happen it's bound to
happen and the reason why it's bound to
happen is because you keep telling lies
that you know our [__] lies that's
that and that's why I tell you in 10 15
years the people who have Trump Flags
draped over him that loved when he came
when the toxic chemicals that he spilled
in their town he came and he he [__]
threw bottles of water and signed their
hats they're gonna [__] hate that
[__]
because he's gonna be gone he's gonna be
gone and no one no one around Trump is
going to be helping them
with with the effects that these toxic
chemicals have on their Community for 10
or 15 years and then when they find out
the truth that Obama was the one that
wanted to regulate these rail cars so
they wouldn't they it wouldn't [__]
spill in their community and Trump's the
one who took the regulations off that
caused it
wait till they find that [__] out and I
know you're like oh Tony it'll never
it'll never change their mind oh time is
a [__] time and Truth ooh buddy
time in truth really has an effect
it really does I mean we're we're on I
mean Trump's still around he's still
around he's still showing up at these
places
he's still showing up at these [__]
that that's that's why the time and the
truth hasn't caught up with each other
yet but it's gonna bite him in the ass
and it's gonna bite these supporters in
the ass it really truly will
it really truly will
it will and then and one of the reasons
why is because it was Democrats that
passed an infrastructure Bill to
actually build
these tracks and these cars better
to have more infrastructure more money
for infrastructure what Republican oh
Republic this is this is this is Maga
this week maga's like oh we need to have
more regulation on train cars and we
need to have more funding more Federal
funding bigger government
bigger government because we just can't
stand that there was one toxic spill in
Trump country
that that's why that's why and that's
why they don't like the truth but listen
Fox News is in a world of hurt here
with the truth
uh another clip I want to show you here
and it's kind of out of context but I
don't give a [__] I want to show this
one to you this is crazy [__] I've
showed you this guy before let's see
what what the [__] his name hang on a
second let me let me get his name uh
[__] I don't have it
well some [__] uh here we go his name
is uh Stephen Anderson
of the Asbury University oh at Asbury
University I don't know
some kind of [__] weird ass
weird ass church that they got going on
here this guy is a weirdo someone needs
to check on this neo-nazi's wife and his
children if he has them
um you see in the background so it's a
it's a map
someone when I tweeted someone put in
the comments is that a backdrop of Flat
Earth behind
oh my God I at Hunter's hog
uh Great Name by the way uh on your
YouTube channel Hunter's hog ass asks
Barry you I don't know I have no idea
not really sure I've shown this guy
before he's he's a weird [__]
man and when you hear the audience in
clips of him
when they post clips of him online uh
you hear in the audience it's mostly
dudes and you're about to find out why I
mean I've never heard like a cheering of
women
of anything this guy says right
um you're about to find out why but if
you notice it looks like he's got a
three dollar suit he looks like he's
never washed his white dress shirt he
wears the stupid red Trump tie obviously
for obvious reasons no telling what kind
of [__] he's got in this cup here
and it's no telling what this guy's got
on his laptop and how how many times he
slaps around his wife I'm I'm just
speculating you listen to what he says
and you know it'll you'll know what I'm
well let's just play the clip let the
woman learn in Silence with all
subjection period
pretty clear folks
right I suffer not a woman to teach nor
do you serve authority over the man but
to be in silence and the Bible of course
says in First Corinthians 14 let your
women keep silence in the churches for
it is not permitted unto them to speak
although I'm not sure I'm actually
starting to wonder if this is really
true because over at Asbury College oh
okay he's talking about Asbury College
he's talking about it sorry I didn't
mean to confuse that that's right now
I'm remembering the clip uh
that you're going to figure out why I
forgot that part because of the [__] he
says after this
the shitty says after this is [__]
despicable and vile just so [__] out
of touch with 2023. and that again
that's the other reason why this is
going to catch up to him
like this [__] here he's so out
of touch with 2023 like he has no he he
just he just does not live in the same
[__] world that you live in because
cubanon is a hell of a drug and this
idea that they're going to use their
religion to oppress people their
Christianity to oppress people because
that's what they're doing folks this
white Christian nationalism doubt me on
this
and this Q Anon stuff is where it all
comes from it all stems from trumpism
manga the real America First Nazi party
it all stems from that nonsense that
white Christian nationalism they're
[__] Nazis watch what he says oh it's
he thinks it's brilliant
God's clearly pouring out his spirit and
you've got women and [__] and and you
know leading the service so I mean hey
maybe we should just rethink everything
we believe because a bunch of
charismaniacs are having Revival in
Kentucky
oh man he runs right into it doesn't it
maybe we should rethink everything we
know yeah yeah you you should do that
you should do that that's exactly what
you should be doing not doing what
you're doing there you you should be
doing that thing that you said you
should be doing what a [__] bonehead
oh it gets it gets better listen or we
could just go with what the Bible says
okay let me tell you something if you
have this fact getting up and preaching
every house of God just take it to the
bank that's not of God
whoosh whoosh and do you hear do you
hear the uh that the audience now I
tweeted I tweeted this video and said
how many women you think are what are
are there at this service I don't think
a lot of people like oh that there's
there's probably several or more than
you think if you listen to the
background if you listen to who's
agreeing with him it doesn't sound like
there's any women like oh yeah preach it
brother no it's dudes this is a in cell
dude Church
where they go and do an anti-war it's
remember uh Little Rascals you remember
that the He-Man Woman Haters Club that's
what the [__] this is the He-Man Woman
Haters Club this guy the church I mean
you know it's not really a club it's the
sky's just a church
but and keep going he oh he he gets more
vile I don't know how but he does
I don't care if it's the most spiritual
smart woman on the planet I don't care
if she's the most godly woman on the
planet
literally
I don't want to hear what she has to say
behind this Pulpit for five seconds God
damn and you hear you hear the
background they're like right right it's
a bunch of dudes you goddamn right I
mean there's like six of them right
there's like six dudes sitting here
watching this guy but he's broadcasting
it this isn't this isn't someone who
took a videotape of this guy saying this
and they're like exposing him he's
broadcasting this [__]
holy [__]
but I gotta say the He-Man Woman Haters
Church oh boy I'm sure it's Gonna Go Far
I'm sure this thing's just gonna take
off just take off but here's the thing
is that Marjorie Taylor green
Lauren bobert the Republican party
that's what they want is the He-Man
Woman Haters church I know Gabe Sanchez
agrees with me then I I'm almost sure
that he agrees that they want the He-Man
Woman Haters Church did you see this
clip of this guy you didn't yeah he's an
[__] all right and it really I just I
just oh you're still uh you missed the
point is it that Pastor yeah yeah
um
Stephen Anderson the guy that's got the
someone commented is that the map of the
Flat Earth bar
why does he have the map behind him
that's [__] weird man it looks like
he's doing it from his garage because
he's got like a homemade pulpit and
there's like three dudes metal folding
chairs
but yeah
when I see whenever I see his videos
come up and I see the big map it reminds
me of grade school and the teacher would
go to the chalkboard and would pull down
the huge map right you know paper map
that would roll up yeah right for anyone
you know for anyone who uh had one of
those Maps you'll understand the
reference I'm making here but that's
what it honestly reminds me of just a
pull-down map of the world I mean this
one's unlabeled he just kind of assumes
that right Earth is Earth and that's it
right right
I mean he doesn't really want to go
anywhere I mean he wants people to go
back where they came from where she
should go back where he came from which
is a like some kind of [__] [__]
doesn't he look like he smells funny I
mean it just he looks like he looks
smells weird he looks like he's on a bit
of a bender yeah he threw on so when
you're doing uh shows or production you
can have suits that basically are just
velcroed in the back right but when you
put it together then it's just it looks
like you're wearing uh
so you can easily get in and out of it
right right that's what he reminds me of
like he's on a bender wearing one of
those type of rip-off jackets nothing
nothing official
um are you frozen no is Tony Frozen is
that one is it just me or is Tony Frozen
I think it's I think it's just you
you're not frozen you're not frozen oh
you need to go out and come back in go
out and come back in here hang on I
gotta message him go out and come back
is it you or is it me no it is you
it's you
there he goes there he goes
oh
man that's Regina says Tony
at your website should send the pastor
five gallons tank full of of Kentucky
what what
let's see are you there now it's not
Kentucky it's K-Y
okay why I thought Kentucky
jelly or jelly oh that makes more sense
now I see yeah yeah you got your mind in
a Lube getter yeah well you know I mean
when you slip on through in the
religious kind of Route yeah are you
better now is it I think so I think it's
raining right now in my building the way
the Wi-Fi the internet the 5G everything
what do you guys you got elon's internet
or something over there yeah pretty much
man I'm trying to hack into the starlink
to get some Wi-Fi
how is your Friday going so far well
I've got the assets I'm loading them up
nice uh you know how is it going so far
it's good I've got uh for those who are
in my patreon oh cool I've got a what
was that coming your way
after the show I'm thinking I'll finish
it with the next few hours
um but that way you you'll get the early
access to that one and that's me
breaking down George Santos and his
interview that went just [__]
terrible
with the incompetent
Pierce Morgan
does does any of his interviews go well
though I mean just asking no no but this
one I did notice that he had and when I
like because I watched the whole thing
the whole thing is probably like 45
minutes or so did you watch it in a fast
speed or did you watch it in regular no
I had to okay because you know why I had
to go through and I had to find the
moments that I wanted in there so when I
went through the actual um brutal
the actual interview I had to hear both
of them talk so I hear Pierce Morgan
asked questions and I will say this
Pierce Morgan did ask questions that you
know legitimately
brought up some stuff for George Santos
uh so but I had to go through because I
knew and I had an idea I had seen some
clips that people had posted but people
didn't post everything they posted like
two two clips from the interview there
was so much in there so much in there so
I had to go through and listen to the
whole thing
and break down exactly uh what he said
and then it was it was good because like
I said before
um I had a whole bit that I was gonna do
about George Santos but then but then
every week is something new you know
it's what the who the [__] is George
Santos so this episode is literally
dedicated to who the [__] is George
Santos and I go through the whole
interview with him and Pierce Morgan and
I break everything down and I call it
out and I fact check and I bring the
receipts everything
everything well everyone go go check out
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez for all
the extras the behind the scenes and
early access to the what was that
um and you'll be able to see it if
you're not a patreon member eventually
but right right yeah yeah yeah yeah but
but if you want it usually goes up a
couple days after but if you want Early
Access and you want the extras the
behind the scenes and all that stuff and
I'm sure you get plenty of extras are
you doing like bloopers because I know
you got blue listen let me tell the
audience this [__] guy is so [__]
I mean if he if he Twitches his eye
wrong in the video he's like nope you
gotta redo it gotta redo it so I'm sure
there's gonna be plenty of bloopers
right yeah I gotta figure out how I want
to cut those because obviously the
priority is the episode and getting the
episode oh no no we want we want all the
bloopers we want all the bloopers just
cut them in don't think about it you got
to do the anti-gabe Sanchez way you got
to just say it's not perfect I'm gonna
just cut it together and show these
people and let them judge me and that's
what you need to do I think everyone
would love it what do you what is the
chat thing do you want to see Gabe
Sanchez at his finest when he's not
absolutely yeah if you want do you want
me to be like reading the because I you
because I read off the of this you curse
sometimes when you [__] it up oh dude
I'm in here again I'm in the room and
you'll hear me like and I'll just like
I'll say the words too quickly or I'll
like stumble over or or mix them around
something around and be like [__] [__]
yeah definitely put those in people want
to see that that's that's like that's
the what was that that I want that's
what was that's the one I want is the
one I will after this we gotta do like
beeps you know where it's like Boop and
then yeah one right right is it as bad
as the um uh the Trump speech thing when
he was recording and we said no because
I can say yesterday oh okay yeah so you
can manage I can manage I can say the
words that I need to say it's just so
many times and reading and saying it as
I go
uh uh but yeah it's one of those things
where
I'll be like [__]
well so my partner in the other room
she'll be like you know she'll be like
uh are you okay in there or or rather
she'll know not to disturb right because
I'm like well you are yelling [__] yeah
I know I mean I also I think this one I
think there I had three [__] in this
one I mean I usually believed him out
because YouTube is sensitive when you
upload they are sensitive they're
[__] sensitive [__] I was talking
about that earlier they do there's no
sense I had one episode where I said
[__] and then uh YouTube was like oh
it's been flagged inappropriate and I
was like fine I will
I will okay Tony I told you I told you I
told you see now a lot of people don't
get to see his imperfection I get to see
it because he'll send me stuff and he's
like whoa whoa whoa don't do that that
one's wrong I'm like what the hell's
wrong about it he's like this it's not
the right shade of red or something I'm
like Jesus man it looks perfect and then
he sends me a new one I'm like you're
right it was better but you should have
went in we should have went I saw I see
Michelle says I love the the Don not
that one you you can't get ads if you
say [__] yeah that's that's yeah yeah
yeah well that's my that's our problem
here on this channel right is I I tend
to say I just for some reason I don't
know why it happens or I say the word
[__] so weird and I'm that serious when
I tell you I've had people call me and
say Hey you know if you would just not
say [__] and tone it down you could be
like nationally syndicated on radio I'm
like yeah but it wouldn't be it wouldn't
it wouldn't be me everybody like
I mean you could do it but then you'd
have to have someone on the like you'd
have to have a little bit of a delay so
that somebody could go through and bleep
I mean it would be funny to see
to have a you know have an episode
bleeped yeah just a whole whole episode
bleeped maybe I should do that maybe we
should do an episode
just like a one yeah it would be like
because I really do know how to cut I'm
really good at it yeah no I know it's
strategy there's strategy of how I cuss
like there's specific points that you
gotta put these words you gotta say them
in a certain way with a certain you know
kind of
accent like a hillbilly yeah it happens
it happens it is what it is uh I uh Tony
needs a beep button yeah
uh you know sometimes it's like whatever
you know and sometimes like yeah Tony
tone it down tone it down tone it down
Tony
yeah okay all right we'll do that uh uh
I oh I am I just thought of a video this
morning so the people on the patreon
will also get this it's uh it's Don Jr
giving a review of the movie cocaine
bear
oh my god I didn't even think of this
that is fantastic so expect I'm I'm
hoping I'll maybe do that tomorrow are
you gonna go watch it are you gonna go
watch it cocaine no oh yeah oh yeah yeah
I'm gonna go see I was like what I went
I wouldn't ask my my 17 year old son I
was like dude we're gonna have to go
watch this movie he's like no I don't
want to see that I'm like are you what
how am I what did I do to you what did I
do who doesn't want to go see this
cocaine bear movie who does not want to
go see this
um what's the comedian's name I sent you
his video oh uh seis uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah Scott's ice yeah yeah I didn't
realize and then I watched the trailer
again this is a [__] movie yeah so I
was uh I well I was editing this morning
and then
somehow oh I what was I doing I think I
saw Don Jr or or or Junior trending and
I clicked on it and then of course I see
you know the this the quotes and I was
like oh cocaine and then I don't know
how I made the connection but I was like
oh Don Jr should do a review of cocaine
bear so that's what I'll be doing this
weekend yeah that's great well here's uh
for you guys who don't know Scott Seitz
does a lot of
um videos about like employment and job
he's like at Ikea answer right questions
right right right any you know bosses
co-workers type videos uh it's hilarious
I and I've never watched him live but
I've watched some of his stand up he
does some of the same stuff stand up
um and it's just it's [__] hilarious
but he's in the movie and I think he's
in like
he's a paramedic in the movie I don't
you know they make it seem like it was
part of the opening scene almost but I
don't know where it's at in the movie
well I mean he has to he he oh somebody
says I went and saw oh the movie worth
oh nice uh this is in relation yeah
yesterday you were talking about the
movies it's on Netflix definitely watch
it it's really good with Michael Keaton
uh but in the trailer he's a paramedic
and they go to a scene where the bear is
already killing people so I think
there's a bit of a setup because
obviously the cocaine needs to drop from
the plane and the cocaine needs to be
ingested you know like bleach right uh
and uh I mean Don Jr is cocaine Bear
right you know many many people if it
was down
and many people say uh do you think the
bear will actually say Jim Eden in the
movie
uh I think the cocaine bear will will
probably throw out some lines where he's
like excuse me excuse me okay dude the
whole rabbit ear things during the night
I think sometimes sometimes they blend
together like obviously that was you
know uh Trump where he's like excuse me
excuse me guys okay I'm Donald Trump you
know but there's obviously the uh Joe
Biden you know what do you think Don Jr
is trying to impress Daddy when he's
trying to like trying to imitate him oh
yeah yeah he's really trying that I
think that's actually what this is about
is because Donald Trump is always
putting quotes in his post so Donald
Trump Jr always puts air quotes during
Whatever video he's talking about even
when it's not necessary right or it's
just he's [__] so yeah down below is
gonna be you know make sure to hit that
like and smash that subscribe button for
I'm doing a film review about the movie
cocaine bear which yeah let's see let's
see Scott slice's video here on coke
cane bear I'm not getting paid for this
I want to go see this [__] movie
um and uh Scott's a great comedian so
I'm happy that he's in it and I sent you
this video last night I'm like I'm so
happy that he's yeah I was like he's I
didn't even know he was in it and then I
watched a trail this morning and he gets
a whole thing he gets chased by the
[__] player in the ambulance right
like the door falls on him and the Bears
on time I mean really honestly it makes
me really more than anything it makes me
want to go see it just because he's in
it but it is called cocaine bear so who
doesn't want to go see him I mean from
what I read Because this is directed by
Elizabeth Banks so all those uh weak
small dick energy cucks out there it was
directed by a woman a funny woman
but also uh there's talks that she said
that she would be open to doing cocaine
shark because I guess there's a whole
story worry about a shark that ingested
cocaine so wait a second are these true
stories these are true I mean not the
extreme but they are true stories that
these that these animals there was
animals who are all coked up like Don Jr
okay well let's let's watch scat's um
video here on the on cocaine beer here's
what you need to know before you see see
cocaine there
nothing you don't need to read a comic
book from 1978 the bear wasn't
introduced at the end of the eternals if
you've ever heard the words cocaine or
bear before you're completely up to
speed don't come to this movie for a pop
quiz okay as Nicole Kidman said we come
to cocaine bear for magic and you're not
going to see any articles after Like
Cocaine bear ending explained you're
just gonna see ones that say remember
the ending of cocaine bear we do too it
[__] rules this movie will be
conservatively one billion times better
than Citizen Kane conservatively
conservatively conservatively uh and if
you uh go follow scan too because you
won't be disappointed uh on his uh
social media videos somebody says that
stash is fake uh as [__] and that stash
is real that stash is really ketchup
that is real that's his real stuff she
has it in the movie too yeah when he has
it in all his videos all his stand up
like if you go watch his stand-up same
same thing yeah um
I'm going to thank Scott for his tweet
there for his uh that that video's got
like three million views on them oh yeah
nice on Twitter so it's pretty pretty
sweet so the cocaine Bears gonna be hot
I think it's gonna I think it's gonna be
all the hot all the rage right and of
course here we make it into politics
we're like uh and you're like Don Jr
yeah I mean it was like oh who would who
would do a movie review
here's the thing here's the thing I know
why Gabe Sanchez is doing this as Don Jr
other than the obvious that he's a
cokehead is that he wants to get the Don
Jr makeup on you it's been a long time
since
somebody commented on a tweet the other
day that said
uh Gabe are you still doing sketches and
I was like yeah I mean there's a whole
story of why I took a bit of a pause I
was focusing on this show I was doing
what was that but I am doing more
sketches and I am getting back into it
it's just a lot of work to make a sketch
to write it to film it to edit it and
then post it and then the next day
someone's like where's the next one and
I'm like oh Mike give me a second it's
just me I don't have a team right well
you know we should we should um I'll
help you out with some commercials
because uh people love uh the
commercials oh yeah they were commenting
there are some there are some more I've
got a George Santos infomercial oh uh
that I have an idea for I've got a
Kimberly Guilfoyle infomercial tell me
what you got I'll see if I can fill in
the gaps and we can then we can get
those done we can get those done and get
them on the show so people can enjoy
them because we play the same ones over
and like when we first started we're
like oh we're gonna have to do new ones
like every week and everyone's like hell
no we love these ones
because I've been playing uh trucker
Convoy here uh the last week or two and
everyone loves that trucker content yeah
that was a good one because we had what
we made like three of those videos I
think yeah two or three of them yeah I
mean it was you know again the freedom
Convoy right right but it's all the same
it's all it you know yesterday when
Trump went and passed out hats and
Trump's poison that I mean excuse me
Trump water right yeah at uh at
McDonald's
um it's the same it's the same [__] man
people I'm so identified I did a mashup
yesterday
of uh yeah yeah yeah that you had put on
YouTube that I put on YouTube which is
sliced alone the one that we showed
yesterday exactly so I put that together
and was like all right this was
obviously this time and then in 2007
here's the video Sylvester Stallone and
I saw some people so I went to go see a
movie last night and not cocaine bear I
want to go see a movie yeah well I it
wasn't at the theater I was at and did
you go Ant-Man I did Ant-Man yeah is
that what is the one yeah yeah it was
good okay that was great I loved it yeah
um and I you know I love Paul rudding
he's great right um who doesn't like
Paul Rudd yeah right you know so anyway
what happened was I got out of the movie
and I got these notifications on my
phone that were like oh some people
commented on the video and then there
was like 2024 I love Trump one person
wrote one person wrote they're like oh
like everyone should be like I like
Trump but everyone should be able to
like laugh at the joke like you know
some light-hearted or whatever then I go
in and I see that the person commented
again and they went in this [__]
diatribe that was like oh you're
one-sided and you're you're uh you're
partisan politics and this and that and
I'm like okay first off I'm making jokes
I'm mocking the Republican party but
what I said to this person I went back
and forth and then he didn't really get
what I was saying because he was like
okay great conversation glad we could
keep it civil and I'm like yeah I was
[__] making fun of you the whole time
but also
in addition to that it was the fact that
I was like as soon as the Republican
party stops uh stripping bodily rights
from women stops attacking the lgbtq
plus Community stops taking and
suppressing the vote of marginalized
communities stops uh you know or
actually funds veterans in their health
care things like that just basic those
are just like four right there if they
start doing that then sure I'll stop
mocking Republicans but until then I'm
gonna still [__] call them out and
they don't have to do it all day helping
Americans are Democrats if they were
doing something as bad as Republicans
yeah I'd call them out Antonio I
certainly call out Democrats and people
within the left you know tyt Pac-Man
other people who have this defeatist
ultimatum attitude we call those people
out and we call the events right like we
should be politicizing I went after pod
saved America the other day right and
they're all they're the they're the
they're the their Hail that is the best
ever they [__] suck right you [__]
second I'll keep going on I don't give a
[__] so yeah I saw this person comment
and then they were like oh well you
shouldn't be porterson and I kept
bringing up and I was like and the one
person's like this guy's uh Trump has
done so much good for America and I was
like please list five things five things
and they couldn't and then eventually
like okay great conversation glad we
keep this civil right yeah you're
probably like some 12 year old kid that
hasn't voted yet and doesn't know what's
going on in the world that your parents
say I got this troll over on Instagram
and he is obsessed with me I mean it
doesn't matter what I post he'll [__]
comment four or five times on the video
so I I took the slide video yesterday
because I'm like oh I have to share this
with the world
and um I sent it I clipped it up I put
it on my Instagram I put it on several
other uh social media just the clip I
didn't do anything fancy like you I just
I just I just robbed the clip and put it
up [__] that I'm not that fancy
um and and I even I even sent it to oh
you know this I sent it to the my
zealous brother so they get Sprinter I'm
like this thing needs to be spread
around Earth all over the place this has
to be like everyone has to know about
this video and this troll was like oh
how desperate of you to play this video
I'm like
how it's even more desperate that you're
commenting on a coat [__] like just
because you don't like to hear that
Sylvester Stallone Rambo a guy who's
supposed to be for Trump wouldn't wash
his [__] nasty socks in his water
that that triggers you like it's funny
as [__] that video is so funny because
it's not real like like Sylvester
Stallone he it's it's an expression I
wouldn't even wash my socks in it yeah
and then the fact that it ends up being
Trump's water [__] triggers these
little these Cuts just triggers these
manga cooks and they're it's so easy to
get under their skin that's why we will
do this every [__] weekday Monday
through Friday till now until Kingdom
Come [__] and did you know yeah oh they
say did you know
uh because I know obviously a bunch of
those [__] Bros who are you know Maga
and all that stuff are like celibate
because like women you know they make
shoes to not have sex when all that [__]
right and they're like porn is bad right
did they know that Sylvester Stallone
did porn he did one porn film he did a
porno he did a porno is it on PornHub
I think you can I think you can find on
a pornhub or even just Google maybe
those those cuck Bros those Trump cuck
Bros can go look it up I will say this I
did I did I was like no way is this real
so I looked it up and I did watch part
of it and I was like this is the
weirdest [__] [__] ever it's like
people are naked but they're not really
having it's weird it's a weird [__]
porn well it's old it's like running
around in a [__] bedroom right but
here's the thing is porn was different
back then because you couldn't do
certain things that's what they want to
do now is they don't want you to be able
to express yourself yeah they don't want
that they don't want freedom of
expression so it took a long time to get
to the point where we can have some
decent nasty porn you know that people
want to watch and it wasn't somebody
says it was soft core I don't even think
this was soft core it was like flaccid
core right like it was just what's below
software yeah I mean really honestly
most of these most of these Netflix
series are more solid oh yeah
there was some show the other day uh it
was it was uh what was it there's some
show and the guy was I it was [__]
what I was like what the [__] the dude
was just in the shower and then he looks
over it's like some uh gym shower and I
guess his wife was cheating on him so he
followed the guy went into the showers
with him at the gym and then they
[__] just full on full frame oh yeah
16 by nine just dick right there and I
was like oh my God hey all the hunter
Biden people would love that [__] oh
yeah oh they'd [__] love that show
you know they obsessed but hey if people
don't know this porn actually is the
thing that has advanced certain aspects
of Technology the reason that you have
high quality video the reason the reason
why you're watching this right now the
way you're watching it is porn porn the
reason why you can buy [__] on Amazon
with your credit card porn porn so don't
be knocking porn porn is good porn's
good for our society
Right video quality and e-commerce right
it's it's important stuff porn porn is
ruining but that's why I support it it's
only that reason yeah it's not because
it's
[Music]
all right everyone uh we're gonna skip
to another subject here what's let's get
to mocking let's get to mocking Maga
your favorite segment of the week
bonehead of the week as soon as we come
back from these messages
maybe it's trucker Convoy maybe it is
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way we
have plenty of Slam jams
skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show you might want
to put earbuds in when we're talking
about porn I'm just saying
uh Jacqueline she might have an issue
over there it happens sometimes
get off on topics who knows who knows
what can happen here on the Tony
Michaels podcast like right now we're at
bonehead of the week
we're definitely we're gonna go over
today for sure it took us a while to get
here yeah it feels like that's what's
gonna happen that's what's gonna happen
I think so
um let me see if I can pull up that
comment there it is Jacqueline oh my God
I was paying attention and Mike I was
not paying attention oh not paying
attention why am I watching softcore
porn putting earbuds back in
happens
Michael's podcast if you don't if you
don't like the porn talk if you don't
like um to be entertained for people out
there that don't want to be entertained
in the chat then see it's not all
apologize
if you don't like it if you don't like
it hit the bricks hit the bricks I don't
give a [__] just remember when you do
your daily affirmations yeah make sure
to uh thank porn thank porn yeah yeah it
is true I would like to thank porn for
today's technology that I use can you is
there a porn God you can pray to I don't
know depends for some people it could be
Stormy Daniels for other people it could
be Hunter Biden for other people it
could be whoever right it's whoever oh
you got a whole list of ones you like
Sonic
I could go to Pornhub and I could see
who's trending and we can just run
through that list we can just run
through that list who's number one on
PornHub today oh my my God okay well
who's number one on bonehead of the week
that's what these this audience really
wants to know so let's get into it bone
end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just kidding no one is guessing
are and wondering who won the bonehead
of the week everyone knows exactly who
won the bone of the week you want to
know a fun fact really easy yeah go
ahead it was almost I like like point
less than one percentage Point uh in
each of the the uh the YouTuber on on
YouTube and Twitter when I looked at it
you were like oh who won I all I had to
do was look it was like 24.72 like six
or right it was gonna be obvious
it was hands I was like oh the same the
same the same got it great okay cool
right across the board yeah and it you
know it said we didn't have anyone new
this week did we are these are these uh
JD Vance was the first this is the first
time he's appeared on bonehead of the
week this morning I was like oh I'm
thinking last night I was like oh I've
got JD Vance in in the gallery yeah I
would have said we had him too no we
didn't it's the first time wow well
congratulations JD at least you made it
on the list for the very first time
everyone give it up for JD Vance for
making him for the very first time on
loan of the week JD you are now on the
list
and we're gonna go through why JD was um
was that should we do him first that's
probably what we should I mean why not
you know it's his first time appearing
we should give him the pleasure yeah of
being the first that we mock here
um why why did you because you kind of
made this list last night we were we
were late to the list again and someone
reminded us
that the
um
that the list needed to go up right yeah
that told me to go up yeah it was we had
JD Vance not JD Mandel or JP Mandel or
whatever it is right now we've
interviewed JD Mandel before but that's
a different guy right totally different
guy totally different guy and the reason
that JD Vance is on the list this week
is because you know he decided to take
the train derailment in East Palestine
Ohio seriously he said hey finally
finally finally it took him 10 days to
release a statement from his office
because remember on February 3rd when
the train derailment happened and [__]
was on flames and in flames and it was
over he had a gun acting like he was
going to shoot down the Spy balloon does
he represent Ohio in some capacity is
that why this is so significant he got
he was just elected Senator oh kind of a
big thing I see kind of a big you know
especially when you're like hey federal
government we need your help however
that's not quite how Ohio likes to do
things I guess right it is funny how
these Republicans JD Mance included all
of a sudden now that there's a trump
District in Ohio that has been
um that has been
destroyed by the deregulation of
Republicans Trump specifically and the
Trump Administration specifically and
the Republican Governor there and the
Republican Congressman will not request
a federal disaster so that the
government the federal government is
kind of handcuffed at what they can and
can't do because it's not deemed a
disaster at this point so
um but it is kind of funny when you see
you know
[__] like JD Vance show up and
swirl a stick in the creek
um because this is JD Vance you know
what this reminds me of this reminds me
of the meme where it's the guy the
little cartoon do something do something
this is JD Vance me like do something
clean up clean up awesome come on uh
this is this isn't very long but it
shows how stupid JD Vance is and how and
really how out of touch he is watch this
I want to look and we'll see this in the
camera but watch this
this is disgusting and the fact that we
have not cleaned yeah yeah the the train
crash the fact that these chemicals are
still seeping in the ground is it insult
to the people who live in East Palestine
um this guy is going to deregulate
trains more and he wants deregulate
industry more that will for more toxic
chemicals into that Creek same dude
right Am I Wrong same guy same guy who's
now realizing that chemicals such as
like oil you know separate from water
you know whoa uh and he's like look
sillions this is cool and he's just
playing around we know JD Vance is a
[__] idiot let's just say that but JD
Vance also is a performative idiot this
guy doesn't know how to actually
represent the people of Ohio what he
does is he you know
[__] and moans about little things
here and there obviously walks uh
stepping you know right in line with
Trump doesn't do anything that's outside
the norm but now Republicans like JD
Vance have become environmentalists they
all of a sudden decided you know what we
need to take this up as a real issue
because it happened in the state of Ohio
under the Biden Administration but
obviously as we'll learn from another
bonehead we have on the week There's a
specific reason why a trained derailment
like this actually happened in a state
like Ohio but Republicans don't want to
admit that it's actually that they're
the
problem well I mean why would they do
that but you know speak
JD Vance loving science
he loves science so much that the same
day that the spill happened like you're
saying he took this picture where he was
he thought he could shoot this rifle yep
60 000 feet in the air and shoot a
balloon out of this guy that's what he
that's what he thought
JD Vance was looking up when he should
have just been looking forward and down
you know like there's a train derailment
and it's leaking [__] into our
environment that is Ohio right my
constituents are being affected by this
and I represent them and I should do
something however it took 10 days 10
days so when I hear Republicans
just completely complain and whine about
how
uh you know
mayor Pete isn't coming into town you
know Buddhist isn't coming into town to
uh deal with the situation and then when
he finally does they make fun of him
wearing a hard hat and safety glasses
because God why the [__] he was by
the goddamn wreck right
so when you when you've got Republicans
like JD Vance who complain and they're
like oh well you know you Joe Budden
isn't doing anything you know he's not
coming here and it's like yeah you took
almost you took a week and a half a week
and a half
to actually do something not even do
something to actually just put out a
statement you know minivans did nothing
this makes me wonder the creek video now
that I'm looking at this picture JD why
didn't you have your sidearm and your
rifle there to shoot the Train the train
cards I mean guns solve everything I
mean you could have swirled the rifle
into the creek and done the same thing
that the stick dig but you chose a stick
what a what what are you some kind of
libtard or something don't you know
don't you know that rifles are the only
thing used to protect America couldn't
you have had your sidearm with you come
on there's a part of me there's a part
of me that he would be like oh no no no
I care more about my guns rights and I'm
not going to ruin the medal by putting
it in water or or water that has
chemicals in it right or you know acidic
chemicals uh he I don't know part of me
goes he's like I value the life of my
gun more than the value of the life of
the constituents in the state that I
represent I honestly think that's why he
took a stick because he's like ah [__]
this dick but if it was his rifle he'd
be like I don't want to rule the rifle
you know but the same reason that you
have to be careful when you touch you
know the metal or the barrel the gun
with the oils off your skin you can
actually ruin the metal and that's why
you have to clean it but I I don't think
that's uh you know I I think that's
that's why he didn't bring the gun you
know he cares too much about it for
anyone who lives in the country near a
creek like this
if you don't know I I don't know if you
know this but if you don't know this is
the reason why they tell you not to
drink out of a creek or a Waterway like
this and the reason why is because it's
not just that this spill happened and
that the Creeks do this because because
of a toxic Trump dump that happened in
Ohio like this you can almost probably
do this to just about any Creek
in a republican area of this country and
it's going to look like that it's going
to do that and the reason why is because
there's so much [__] dumped into
waterways because they're not regulating
it I don't know it's almost like when
when they voted Donald Trump in Ohio and
dewine and and JD Vance it's almost like
they want politicians that'll make sure
chemicals get into their waterways so
that it'll do this for these kind of
photo ops because that's exactly what
happens because it's not Republicans
that are trying to protect clean air and
clean water they're doing the exact
opposite matter of fact the last [__]
Republican that was President barely by
a technicality frankly put someone in
charge of the EPA who was rolling back
clean water and clean air regulations so
spare me spare me the [__] and spare
me the [__] photo ops because there's
plenty of creaks where there hasn't been
a railroad car spill that if you drag a
stick through it JD Vance that are gonna
do this and it's because of people like
you that don't give a [__] about people
in those communities that rely on those
waterways so and it's not just not just
the water too right we're also talking
about the the life that is in that area
so you've got Birds squirrels uh you
know deer other other animals that that
depend drinks from them on that water
right they go there you know whatever is
left of that Creek bed they they rely on
that water as a source of of of of
sustenance and so when you say oh look
how bad this is for my constituents well
yeah it's not just the constituents who
might be affected because of land nearby
but also the animals that obviously feed
into this whole uh way of life right one
animal consumes another animal that
animal you know like you're finding
you're finding this whole way back it's
not just the water like directly
drinking the water but it's also the way
in which you follow it back on you know
a meal right the ingredients that go
into that meal whether it's vegetative
or it's actual meat
um you're gonna find that this water and
this these chemicals are going to are
going to Loop in another way right so
it's not just the water that I have to
worry about it's everything else that
relies on that water
uh but Republicans don't make the
connection they're always like oh this
is the only problem nothing else is ever
ever going to be impacted by this
they're very you know short-sighted and
narrow-minded and unable to accept the
fact that there's an ecosystem and
everything is connected
hmm
you know science it's almost like they
believe grifters and Liars which brings
us to the next bone end of the week this
is definitely not the first time this
[__] bonehead has been on here Trump
now there is there's like four or five
reasons per day that this [__] could be
ongoing of the week but obviously and a
lot of a lot of them for him are are
submission like self-submissions right
this is right I mean he's he's doing in
him of his own volition here it's not
like anyone's forcing him or painting
him into a corner it's kind of like this
idea where he went to to East Palestine
in the air P Palestine yeah Palestine
Ohio I keep saying Palestine but you
know it happens that way it's like Rodeo
Rodeo it's like salsa yeah not so much
the salsa thing salsa no it's salsa you
get your chips and your salsa um anyways
and in East Palestine Ohio Trump shows
Palestine Palestine that's what I said
Palestine no I said Palestine oh who's
on first yeah right no what's on second
I don't know who's on third
um in Ohio damn it in this little town
in Ohio Donald Trump shows up to uh sign
Maga hats at the McDonald's and throw
bottles of trump poison I mean water at
these people
um and he thinks that's all better he
didn't actually go visit the site he
didn't actually meet with any kind of
like officials where he could change
anything because he can't he doesn't
have any power anywhere he's worthless
he is uh effectively worthless yeah even
if he has power but I want to show you
this video here I think it's very
relevant and then I'll show you why
these people are doing what they're
doing
um this is this is really [__] weird
there's a lot of things weird about this
oh my God these are these are kids that
go to they're we're not we're not
indoctrinating these kids folks right
right now if you look up your if you can
see uh up here on this I think it's a
house I don't know it might be a
commercial property there's a lot of
cars there's caution tape here I think
it's a house and a bunch of people are
are using it as their home base right
well this is like I think this is the
the route that he took right so like
they got caution tape right you know
they were trying to block off the street
and then obviously because they knew it
was the route they were hanging up a
sign that says thank you Donald Trump I
I don't know if they're thanking him for
the spill they're like thanks thanks for
giving our community attention by
destroying it I don't know what they're
thinking
so there was a comment on the video that
I posted about Sylvester Stallone
yesterday and matching up him with the
water oh we're gonna show that too Sloan
and I had a comment that I saw yesterday
was like well at least he's doing
something and I was like yeah he would
have been doing something and even ever
cut and gutted the safety train
regulations he went and he signed hats
and he gave out bottles yeah he could
have shipped bottles of water to this
town yeah what the [__] are they talking
about it's the same reason doing
something it's like when people like oh
yeah at least he went to Puerto Rico and
did some he threw paper towels at people
well you know what he did Puerto Rico
flooding do you know what he really did
in Puerto Rico that Puerto Rico should
thank him for he made sure to stop
hundreds of millions of dollars of
funding and cleanup effort in Puerto
Rico after the hurricane Oh that's oh my
God thank you Donald Trump oh my God
you're such a great attention to the
fact that he did nothing or not that he
did nothing he made sure
that we did nothing he was like oh no
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna address it
he goes no no we're gonna make sure that
nobody gets funding and we're gonna hold
it over their head to make sure that
they do what we want all right that's
that's Donald Trump if Donald Trump
could he would say you won't get this
shitty old water unless you vote for me
in 2024 right well here there's another
thing before we even play this clip
or something else in this just this uh
screenshot here and I feel sorry for
these kids actually because they're
being groomed I don't know if you notice
but they have Trump Flags draped over
them as as if it's as if he's some sort
of Messiah or some [__] this is [__]
weird stuff and these aren't like old
tattered Trump legs these are brand new
you can still see the folds in them
because this is something that happened
in some of those videos where he was
walking around and [__] what happened is
that everyone knew he was going to come
to this town so a bunch of [__]
grifters who sell Trump merch and Trump
just Trump nonsense like sweaters and
hats and all this [__] and these flags
all of them came to town to Griff these
people these people had are complaining
they have no money now they're gonna
have to spend a bunch of money which
they are it's it's their own problem
they voted for the guy they voted for
this they voted to deregulate trains so
they could crash in their communities
and spill toxic chemicals everywhere
that's what they voted for that's what
Republicans want that's what they want
to continue to do that's what you're
[__] voting for so you voted for this
and and a lot of people were pissed off
at Joy Behar for saying that on a view I
was the first one too that I [__]
said it first Ohioans are to blame here
they are to blame listen if 2016 would
have went to Hillary Clinton instead of
Donald Trump we'd live in a different
[__] world right now so don't don't
give me the [__] about you didn't
vote for this you've been voting for
this for a long time Ohio and you're
grooming your children look at this [__]
they're grooming their kids now
you're gonna listen to this and what
they're talking about is the drinking
Fountains at their schools listen to
what these kids say about the drinking
Fountains at their schools brother he
was like laying next to the air vet and
he got a rash on his uh cheek and then
like we've all been having like runny
noses since it happened and like
headaches and stuff and then when we go
out of town in like Robinson or
something where we feel better and then
when we come back it's like happened
again you don't have to really crazy
about this is because
um I almost feel like the way that these
kids have been trained to talk about
this from the bone-headed parents the
ones that drape the Trump Flags over
them who are grooming them to love the
guy who spilled the toxic chemicals all
over their Town
um it almost feels like to me
when when this when this kid is groomed
to say that we drink water here and we
are here and then we go to another town
for a few hours we feel better right
that's not how it works that's not how
it works it's the same way yeah now this
morning I said I don't know who these
parents are but uh shame on them number
one for um letting these grooming these
kids by draping Trump Flags over but
here's the thing is that it's I almost
met the same parents would be like Cove
it's fake and even if you get it it's
just a cold you just get a sort of a
rash and a sore throat you just you kind
of get your eyes watery it's no big deal
it's no big deal you get over it you get
you get immune from it listen if you're
so tough and you people are so [__]
tough there in Ohio and because you're
Republican and your Patriots then get
over it what are you worried about these
toxic chemicals for you're just gonna be
immune from the toxic chemicals that's
all it is
immunity that's all you're doing and
maybe and that sore throat you're just
billing immunity I don't know and maybe
if you're lucky if you get the chemical
chemicals spilled on you maybe you'll
get some superpowers right maybe it'll
be like Daredevil or you know super
Trump or Alex Mack or you know for those
who watched uh Nickelodeon but this is
one of those things where
it's not just like you know parents and
these kids regurgitating these talking
points where they run right into the
point to say uh oh hey we shouldn't be
in this town anymore or we shouldn't be
here while this is happening we should
leave or we should get resources or what
have you but the idea
is I don't want to say like I don't
believe these kids but there is a part
of me there is a small part of me
where
I look at the the length of time when
this interview was and when when this
bill happened
and when they're saying oh the kid put
his face to the vent and he got arrested
maybe it was because maybe it's because
of something else or maybe the kid never
got a rash at all the drinking water
maybe the water wasn't was a was
affected that quickly I don't know
but there's a part of me too not to say
again not to say that I don't want to
believe these kids
but there is a part of me you know to
the point that you made which is these
parents told them what to say they were
like oh make sure that so and so little
little Bobby got a rash and and Susie
Anne uh you know drank the water and she
got sick and then we went to town
there's a part of me where they told
those kids to say that and those things
may have not happened now I'm not saying
that it won't happen in that town
because obviously like I said there's a
whole ecosystem and everything's
connected and it will eventually impact
every aspect of your life whether it's
the air you breathe or the water you
drink or the food you eat or whatever or
the Trump hat you get or the you know
the Trump water you decide to crack open
but in any one of those scenarios
eventually I do see that as a
possibility for sure
but there's also a part of me that says
oh did the parents tell these kids to
say that so they could own the libs and
make sure that Biden looked bad
when it's like hasn't come to that yet
they definitely they definitely bottom
the Trump flags to hang over in during
the interview now these kids go on to
talk about the drinking Fountains at
school listen to what they say
come into town like our eyes start
burning and stuff
my nose has just been really runny
that's it my left eye I have like it was
burning and my mom has chemical burns in
her eyes and um like
it's gross something else too uh when I
like take a shower with the shower water
I end up getting like Burns all over my
legs like it itches and burns
and uh have you all been back into
school now since this what has it been
like in school uh so far it's
yeah but yeah
but they closed the water fountain
Fountain I think kids are just going up
there and drinking the water yeah I
don't drink the water in the first place
I know I don't drink the water either
the drinking water fountains in the
schools are not blocked off yeah they're
not blocked off they let you drink out
of them still
they wouldn't want these kids wear masks
during kovitz so it's not surprising
that they have the poison fountains open
why is this why would this be surprising
in a republican area like this that they
still have the [__] I thought Trump
brought all the water they needed to
have at the school for these kids to
drink I don't know again like I don't
want to be that guy who's like I don't
believe the kids but I don't there's
something about this story that doesn't
quite add up right like the fact that
they're saying maybe they're more
sensitive to this stuff right uh but the
fact that they're like oh I'm burning
when I take a shower and my eyes burn
and chemical burns and my you know my
mom said she got a chemical burn in her
eyes
you know maybe again maybe I I don't
want to put down on this but there's a
partner it's like well I would assume
that if this was the case right and
obviously I know that with uh
you know the combination of the moisture
in there that does happen and it does
create more of an acidic rain uh with
the chemicals but
I haven't heard
those same things from reporters right
if they're staying in hotels they're
they're out and about they're nearby the
other the other thing is happening the
other thing too is
um we talked about this I think
yesterday about respirators no one's
wearing respirators because there hasn't
there hasn't been a change in the air
quality there like there's just not a
change in the air quality I mean I'm
sure you could look up an aqi score
right like here I'll just I'll look
around well and and the thing is is that
respirators only like protect you from
certain things so those certain things
are not in the air to protect you from
so there's no reason to wear respirator
if those things aren't in the air so and
and the FEDS are testing for all this
the EPA has been on the ground since day
one almost the moment it happened the
feds showed up to start evaluating what
the [__] was spilled and how how
contaminated the area was that's one
reason why dewine called everyone back
to the community is because the EPA told
him that yeah the EPA told him that so I
mean this idea that the feds haven't
been on the ground as [__] dumb and
and to be fair the Ohio EPA that that
what is the Environmental Protection
Agency of Ohio has been on the on the
scene too so the state and the federal
visuals have been on the scene but uh to
those kids drinking out of the water
mountains and having rashes and their
parents uh having gross eyes or whatever
the the one kid said uh here's Donald
Trump's message to them this is his
message so I want you to listen up if
you're if you're there in uh in Ohio
this is this is his message to you about
your burning eyes and your your poison
water fountains here's what he has to
say you know that nice to see you thank
you have a good time you look so good
you have a great time have a great time
have a great time have a great time do
you think that Trump thought of these
people when he cut regulations and like
he had a whole wait wait wait a whole
day no wait wait wait wait wait wait he
thinks about these people that's what
I'm saying do you think he thought about
these kids no absolutely not the
Republican party is all about saving the
children yeah right it's the it's the
same ones in Alaska where they want they
want abused children to die because it's
cheaper on the state yeah okay yeah I
got it um here is the uh here's the
water here's the water clip because we
gotta show this this is the um where
he's talking about his Trump well
actually you know what load your [__]
version in do you have your version
handy
straight up on here yeah sure just put
it well wait no you you posted yeah it
sounds it sounds like did you tweet the
video or just the YouTube link oh just
the YouTube link oh God you're killing
me I'm sorry I'm sorry buddy Jesus
Christ
while you're doing that I'll get the
video of him cutting the ribbon
oh yeah that's perfect yeah let's do
that because that was a boneheaded
moment that he's gonna pay for for a
long time too oh yeah where the [__] is
that okay there it is all right you
didn't just post that straight up on
Facebook no yeah I shared it here look I
shared it with people on the what was
that patreon and then I put it on
YouTube and I made it public and tweeted
it out and guess who the other water is
whatever can you hear it now yeah I can
hear it oh okay oh well [__] it shows
there I didn't know that that did that
okay well see I'm a bonehead all right
here's the uh Boomer Boomer I mean
thousands of bottle of water Trump water
actually
that's the better water are you serious
and guess who the other water is
whatever it is I wouldn't wash my socks
what Trump ice
oh my God
Trump ice oh it's too good I I I I bet I
watched that I bet I watched that video
six billion times yesterday for some
reason that number stands out to me but
that number does stand out but before we
get there we should probably show this
up yeah well I know I know seven million
I mean who knows actually 6 billion
probably is the same number of documents
that Trump allegedly thought there was
to be handled for regulations that he
said this is what we have today and we
can't have that right that looks like
six billion I that that could it might
be Six Trillion or six gazillion oh man
possibility that's a lot of that is a
lot of billions how many words do you
think is printed on this paper or do you
think they just brought in rings I think
I think they brought in reams of paper
yeah the same way that during the 60
Minutes interview I think it was with
Trump uh Kaylee mcanany gave a big book
to
to the interviewer which I'm blanking on
her name right now
um
and gave her a blank book it was just a
bunch of white pages in a book and
they're like this is his health care
plan right the one which was blank which
was true which was true it was
completely had a cover on it and it was
blank because Trump had no health care
plan and he kept saying in two weeks in
two weeks in two weeks an interview with
Chris Wallace in two weeks in other
interviews during debates in two weeks
Everyone is always two weeks with this
guy but but but he did do this promise
here this was a promise he kept because
if anyone's confused this is from 2017.
and one of the regulations that is on
The Chopping Block here is one that was
put in by the Obama Administration two
years prior in 2015. wait why would he
do that though why why why would he do
what why would Obama put regulations in
place because what he wanted to do is he
wanted to protect communities from toxic
chemical spills by making sure that that
the rail cars because each I don't know
if people know this but each rail car
has its own braking system did you know
that's how they stop yeah each one of
those cars has its own braking system
that's how they stop and he what he
wanted to do is he wanted to put a
specialized braking system to make it
safer for tanker cars to carry toxic
chemicals ah that that's crazy Tony
right that sounds like crazy [__] that
sounds like big government to me man
okay it's almost like that's what
Republicans are bitching that that they
want now which they're gonna run into
let me tell you something they're gonna
run into and and I don't know if you
know this but Pete Buda judge and the
bite Administration are gonna play them
like a fiddle on this because they're
gonna they're gonna walk into all kinds
of regulations on industry in the next
in the next probably 12 to 18 months and
Kevin McCarthy is going to be forced to
bring some of this [__] to the floor and
they're gonna have to vote on it because
they're bitching and moaning and
complaining and if they don't guess what
we get to do we get to [__] point it
out that they're not doing what they're
complaining about so I mean it's the
same way when it's the same way when
they talk about being you know Pro
veterans and wanting to support veterans
and then they don't support veterans the
same reason that when you know we Joe
Biden called him out and he's like look
a lot of you not saying all of you but a
lot of you uh or I think he said some of
you is the real one says a few of you a
few of you whatever it might be all them
secretly all of them all of them
that they're going to strip away
Medicare and they're going to take away
Social Security and they're gonna take
away all of these rights and benefits
you know I mean the reason why the
reasons the reason why I gave Sanchez is
a will help companies like Norfolk
Southern get their profits up if they
repeal those those those quote
entitlements well employers have to help
pay for it's if you remove every expense
that a company has bring profits yeah
[__] the employees okay let's see let's
see what he says about the regulations
on the train cars here just keep in mind
that that was one of the ones that he
was considering here is the on the
braking systems that caused not having
the braking systems I should say caused
this spill in Ohio let's watch it so
this is what we have now
this is where we were in 1960 and when
we're finished which won't be in too
long a period of time we will be less
than where we were in 1960 and we will
have a great regulatory climate
okay
come on up here Chris come on
she has a lot to do with it she has
things called roads
the big and bridges right yes okay one
two three
also train braking systems you know the
one he's talking to there it sets Mitch
McConnell's wife and now now that he
hates her and Mitch McConnell he calls
her a racist name oh yeah well I mean
I'm sure
I guarantee he was calling you Lane Chow
bunch of racist names during the
administration right the doors were
closed and he was in another room or she
was off doing something else he for sure
called her racist names I mean Donald
Trump is not one where loyalty actually
stands the guy will backstab you at any
given moment to protect himself I
guarantee if given the opportunity he
will backstab his kids maybe not Ivanka
will see but definitely throw Jared
Kushner under the bus or under the train
when it comes to indictments or cases or
getting charged with actually uh you
know stealing the documents or planning
the coup or inciting the you know all
these things he's going to protect
himself as much as possible he's got two
kids with some other uh you know uh
children in laws that he will happily
throw under under the the the the bus or
the train or you know whatever it might
be to protect himself that is the that
is the Donald Trump way so he'll say
nice things maybe on camera or when he's
working together but behind closed doors
that guy is [__] complaining ranting
yelling
all sorts of derogatory things against
anyone anyone right
well I wonder what derogatory says
things he says against our Alpha cuck
this week Elon Musk I wonder what he
says about him in private Elon Musk oh
that [__] why is he on the alphagook
well not really sure those reasons why
he hasn't been on in a minute but this
week there were some things that came to
light
um around not only Twitter and I'll pull
I'll find the Tweet right now but also
um
his uh his little cyber truck oh look at
this oh wait wait you mean
cyber truck that these
the [__] trumped up white dudes are
supposed to like but it looks nothing
like the trucks that they like is that
the one you're talking about what's
funny what's funny is Elon Musk thinks
that the Trump that guys are gonna buy
this cyber truck that doesn't look like
a truck it doesn't look like the trucks
they want that and and in all reality
Ford Chevrolet uh dimer Chrysler they're
all going to be coming out with EVS that
look like the pickup trucks that these
people want right because the thing is
is Chevrolet GM or GM which is Chevrolet
but Ford dimer Chrysler Toyota all these
manufacturers that are here in this
country have figured out the market like
they pretty well know they got a good
handle on what people want that's why
they keep building bigger and bigger
vehicles and then when gas prices did
soar they're like you know what we're
gonna do crossovers which is just like a
station wagon right yes I mean it's not
an SUV but I mean you know that's the
thing that people want the most
especially those Die Hard uh
American-made muscle cars or the trucks
right they want it to feel they want to
sound they want it to just be if you're
gonna If You're Gonna Go an EV option
they want that same experience right uh
you know and they think gasoline is the
only way to achieve that and there's
other ways that companies are working on
literally right now and they have been
for years to achieve that same
experience right that same feel when
you're like you know [__] throttle
the engine and you've got your hands on
the wheel and you're shifting gears like
they want that same experience they
don't want it to feel like it's less
than because it's you know it's an EV
option right oh it's a little baby
little [__] foot like that [__] they
want to feel like all this [__] Macho
and if you can feel manly while also
helping the environment dude
checks all around right awesome but
we're gonna show that we're gonna show
the Cyber truck right right are we gonna
show that yeah but but first off I want
to show you this is the first week you
sent me here
um it says new Twitter told employees
that slack was down for quote routine
maintenance that's a lie the company
hasn't paid its bill but weirder still
slacked it and shut down Twitter's
Twitter's
instant one what does that mean someone
so
at Twitter mainly shut off access is
instant something that to do with slack
it's uh no it's it well yes so when
an instance for them yeah it's totally
fine so basically when you have a slack
Channel write a company slack Channel
you have a dedicated and especially for
a company an Enterprise company you're
gonna have a whole uh you're gonna have
uh support on the slack side so
basically it would have everything but a
slack Channel let's let's back up a
second guys I know what slack is but
obviously I'm not that educated on slack
is just a just an organizational tool
for for companies to where people can
communicate they can work on projects
together and it's all right there they
can do it the whole goal is right it's
like a digital workspace that's all it
is it's also intended to replace email
because an email you're like responding
to a thread and someone else responds to
a different thread and you know it's
just like a chat room where you guys can
chat about a project right so but but in
this in this case you're saying and and
they're reporting here that Twitter is
not paying its bills which is
significant so basically yeah what
they're what they're reporting here is
that Twitter has failed to report on or
sorry fail to pay uh their bill which
again this is an Enterprise client so
it's going to be a fair fair Bill a fair
size bill there's going to be a lot of
users not that there's as many thousands
of employees but right they still have a
fair amount because they're probably
paying per user per month and that's
typically how a SAS model Works to that
scale right you're getting some custom
deal out of it so Elon I guess isn't a
fan of Twitter or I'm sorry well
probably not a fan of Twitter uh he's
not a fan of slack and he's using some
other
um
some other tool that's called uh uh but
their whole infrastructure was built in
slack well their communication structure
was all right well that's what I that's
what I mean that's what I mean yeah yeah
and so now and so here and the thing is
slack is well also the Twitter files
there's a lot of conversations that came
from slack that they were reporting on
to be like oh gotcha you know uh there
was a lot of stuff from there that they
had pulled out there was a lot of stuff
that Elon because as like a super admin
Elon can jump into any of these channels
whether public or private and see what
people are talking about so from what I
understand on earlier reports maybe a
couple months ago or so Elon was
snooping around inside of slack to
figure out who was saying [__] about
Elon because again tough man Elon Musk
alpha male super fragile ego just like
Trump the guy doesn't like people
talking bad about him the same reason he
had engineers redevelop and fix the uh
the algorithm so that his tweets were
inject were were thrown into everyone's
timeline so they could perform better
than Joe Biden's tweet on the Super Bowl
it's almost like there's a pattern with
these [__] almost yeah almost it's
almost like these guys are so sensitive
and so weak and so fragile and so
delicate like a snowflake that they
can't handle any outside feedback
criticism or anyone saying anything bad
they have to they have to have people
like them and what you realize is that
kind of seems like a dictator you like
me or else and that is what happened at
Twitter because there's a whole other
story here on the engineer see why there
said no questioned or did the job they
were hired to do in a short amount of
time and then he fired them afterward
so you know it's that is something that
a weak person does you know something
that a a
hypocrite and just an [__] does
I grew up with a lot of pickup trucks
games you're up in the country grew up
on a farm we had a pickup truck we had
several of them I my first vehicle that
I bought with my own personal money was
a 1967 Chevrolet C10 two-wheel drive
yeah had a 327 with two speed paraglide
a real [__] truck American-made [__]
feel that vibration in your legs yes it
even had I don't know if people know
this but the the headlights the bright
button is down down on the floor where
you push it with your foot oh yeah
that's pretty cool it's still like some
that's like some Secret Asian [__] and
that it had AM radio in it the bench
seat you know for certain things that
you could do on the bench seat it was a
badass truck right
1967 Chevrolet C10 this doesn't look
like um a truck at all really I mean no
I'm not saying it doesn't look cool but
I'm saying it looks stupid like this
looks like they're trying yeah I mean
the Tesla's out there like the of cars
yeah they they look all right I'm not
I'm you know I'm not gonna knock their
design this is a really shitty design
for a truck yeah it's horrible it's got
a small bed in the back uh right they
said the windows were indestructible and
they threw a little little weighted ball
at it and broke the broke the the window
um because they [__] glowed it and
it's like why would you not why would
you either you know not decide to cut
that
from the from the demonstration or make
sure that if you're gonna throw a metal
object a weighted metal object and say
something is indestructible right
there's also a reason and and this is
what people don't understand I think
about how
physics work
there's a reason why a car will absorb
an impact right
there's a reason how energy is
distributed through a vehicle if
impacted on right like Newton had these
three laws crazy crazy laws uh that
shared how things react not so you're
getting that on the science thing I know
but there's a whole thing [__] them up
you know
why why trucks like this for Consumer
use should not be this like
indestructible bounce [__] off a window
type of [__] that's not how the they're
intended to take an impact
to save
the person inside or else the energy
then gets dispersed not the way that you
want it to be and the person can
actually be injured more well you know
that's why that's why a lot of
Manufacturers went to unibodies in mid
and full-size cars is because the way
that they can manufacture and design a
unibody to take an impact better than
they can than the body sitting on the
frame but you know these things these
things with science and engineering you
just shouldn't go there with these
people what am I about to watch I
actually haven't watched this video you
sent this as a video yeah so should we
should we just play it and then just
play the video there's a guy that
there's a guy that is talking he's
commenting and at first I thought this
guy can't be serious but I actually
believe this is a real Fanboy and if
anyone disagrees feel free to but in the
middle of it I I had my doubts but then
I was like no I think this guy is real
okay well let's watch I feel like
they're gonna drive it up on top of that
foreign
oh baby get up that curb drive over the
bushes
there we go cyber truck off-roading
first time off-roading check that bad
boy out
oh
you gotta be [__] up there cyber truck
[Music]
oh that's bad
this is really horrible yeah that's
really horrible I mean look at that they
had to bring up that little wooden ramp
oh my God over for the Cyber truck to be
able to drive up there like that's kind
of wimpy
oh my God they had to they had to get
the ramps out to get the cyber truck
over the curb so just understand this is
a normal curve that one was probably I
don't know like nine inches you know uh
right standard not crazy and here's the
thing it's also probably a little bit
lower because that's on private property
and that area that that the Cyber truck
had to [__] it off-road on
was something that is used to display
the cars because they're like here at
Tesla we've got these cars they're on
display they had I don't know five six
dudes that were looking around and they
had wedges little ramps to help the car
off-road on a six inch curve off-road
yeah and I use I use like the quotes
off-road like I'm Don Jr
when I was a teenager I drove a I think
it was a 1993 1994 Buick Skylark oh you
know what a Buick Skylark is right I
mean back in the day there were some bad
[__] Vehicles like a two because
they're GM it's kind of like it's kind
of like a a Nova sort of back then but
in the 90s it was a grocery getter right
I mean that's what it was well also it
was like full metal like thing was right
well I mean this this thing well I mean
it had fiberglass fenders on it okay I
mean you know it was it was a grandma
car right yeah yeah but it was the car
that we had that I could drive when I
was a teenager yeah right I mean that
was the Buick was a go-to car for my
grandpa like always like he would you
know this car was not slow it had a V6
in it which uh you know I I had a few
friends that had like eagle talons you
remember like the Mitsubishi Eclipses
and [__] and the Eagles yeah right yeah
yeah they thought they were really cool
and really fast and we would race I'm
not saying I did this I just may have so
if there's any kind of statute of
limitations on drag racing just forget I
said this but I would whip their ass
every time in this car and they would
get surprised because here's a four-door
car but I don't know how many curbs I st
I jumped over with this with a car it
was a Buick it was a car a 1993 Buick
Skylark it was a grandma car and this
[__] Tesla cyber truck can't hop over
a curb to get up with those other cars
what the [__] are you serious and this
is they think they're gonna hang Trump
flags from the back of this Yvonne
because it's really weird to me that he
plays to these people who are never
gonna buy this truck yeah like he
totally should have scrapped this whole
project went to build a truck that's got
a big huge four-door cab it sits 12
inches the the body sits 12 inches
higher than the wheels it's got an eight
foot bed and it's got dualies on the
back yeah why what the f how does he not
know
that that could get over a curb for
crying out loud look I have I have like
a I have a compact SUV and even my car
right even might get over it without it
could make it over like there are some
times when like I'm uh like I'm parking
and I've gotta you know avoid the
garbage uh cans on the street you know
[__] and I get too close and you know
I'm and my back wheel my [__] back
wheels like you know like I'm getting up
on the curb on its own and I'm like oh
gotta turn the wheel fix it but these
guys over here like oh we can't we can't
get this thing scratched we can't let
this thing just like hit the curb pop a
tire
because that it's like dude if if you're
trying to sell this thing as the
ultimate man's technological advancement
for off-roading fun and pleasure
you're gonna tell me that you have to
then say Oh we also sell these
accessories which are get on the edges
little wedges so you gotta park the car
get out reverse make sure that you're
lined up right go up don't make sure
that way you can off-road follow me well
here's the other thing too about this
truck if you didn't see it um and if you
don't if you're just listening this in
the audio form you should go look at
pictures of this truck it looks like one
of the most failed cars in human history
which is a DeLorean that's really what
it looks like yeah which by the way the
DeLorean is coming back well right but
it's it's it was a pile of [__] oh yeah
it was a piece it was the only reason
why we the only reason why we know what
the DeLorean is is because it made its
famous debut uh in feature films and
Back to the Future as a time machine you
know the story behind the DeLorean and
how oh dude I've watched documentaries
on them yeah it's crazy it's a crate
anyone who doesn't know it I think
there's two movies yeah one with Lee
Pace another one uh I forget with who oh
they're well uh Alec Alec Baldwin plays
him in one of them yeah yeah like but
yeah the document I mean like it's a
fascinating story I don't know how how
it was funded and all the crazy [__]
that happened but yeah the reason that
we only know about it is because of Back
to the Future right
I've got a neighbor who um who has one
right and they take it to all the car
shows and stuff so during the summer
there's only enough of them to pretty
much take the car shows anymore yeah but
it'll break down within a couple miles
as as as as cool as the car is because
it was on the movie it is a pile of [__]
so why you would design anything that
looks like the biggest pile of [__]
that's ever been made in car history I
don't know why you would do that it's
almost like it's almost like Elon is an
alpha cook and he's a dumbass yeah
almost like that it's almost like the
guy's not a rocket scientist like we've
been saying for a while now and he's not
a genius the guy is an idiot who just
to the to the right like that's that's
what he does he follows the you know
right wing Republican Maga conservatives
and follows what they do Twitter files
uh letting Trump back on the platform
you know claiming to want to save
children but then he cuts the department
that was in charge of monitoring and
making sure that there wasn't child
pornography on the website the guy is a
hypocrite yeah complete hypocrite and an
idiot speaking of hypocrite
and and someone that Elon would love to
cut to brings us to our dishonorable
mention Tucker
Carlson okay
Charles of white privilege tonight on
fake news uh there's probably 1200
reasons why this guy became the
dishonorable mention this week but why
is Tucker Carlson the dishonorable
mention uh this week you had to have
picked something yeah this week was
dedicated uh you know to one he was
pushing the idea on the train derailment
right you continue to push that idea and
then he's been allowing Margaret Taylor
green to go on to his show to discuss
this National divorce is that the one
you want me to show yeah if you've got
that one that's playing but that's just
one of the things like last night she
went on time that's the roar because she
goes on talks about the war in Ukraine
yeah she's given Putin fellatio it's
right it's weird stuff let's see oh no
oh they say we like Putin it's like yeah
you do your anti-ukraine pro Putin on
all of your propaganda so there's
literally footage of you in 4k saying
these things but yeah Margaret Taylor
green went on Tucker Carlson last night
and she talked about how we shouldn't be
so mean to Putin and we shouldn't give
this money to Ukraine and we should be
investigating where the money's going if
we really want to investigate where
money's going fine let's investigate
where all the PPP money went for
Margaret Taylor green or Matt Gates or
anything otherwise the politicians which
one you want me to play then do you want
me to play the Ukraine one or no I think
the ukrain one is too long unless
there's a clip on it but you just play
the play the one with the national
divorce because it'll lead into the next
one
I'm trying to find that one all
everything says the Ukraine right now
because it happened last night I'm
trying to find trying to find an older
video see that's the again that's the
problem with with Tucker Carlson being
the dishonorable mention is this guy
every night every [__] night this
guy's the dishonorable mention every
night he does a show which is every
[__] night that's why we have to do a
show every day yeah I mean that stuff
gets outdated within hours I mean
sometimes sometimes
there's a good chance that the stuff
comes back up because Republicans are
idiots and they keep running into the
point and making the same mistakes
uh but sometimes it's like within hours
like boom we're done right
um let's see if I can find can you find
that clip of the national divorce
because I'm finding articles about it
but I'm not finding the damn the clip
here of um see what we do is we use
Twitter to uh Elon yeah
you should probably got it
um
Tucker Carlson and Madge oh excuse me
Marge jury Taylor hoof foot green
otherwise known as the pettieri here on
the Tony Michaels podcast
um there's that one yeah it's all the
[__] it's all right now it's all the
um
the Ukraine [__] Russia [__] what she
said last night
um we can just play we can uh you know
what here we'll go we'll just play that
I can't find that clip I mean we'll get
enough of that because it got buried it
got buried it got it it's it definitely
got buried so find that find the divorce
clip
um for for the next segment everyone
knows who the bonehead is yeah um but
you know uh let's see but if we want we
can play uh here we'll play oh here I
got a great one this is a great one this
is a great one of him and him and the
petty Eddie on foxy you can see Tucker
Carlson here he's real confused about
wine look at that freeze french show
just just like the cheer that she was
doing at the State of the Union last
year and this year too
Margaret Taylor green the woman of no
class
okay uh let's see what she says about
Tucker hearing the truth you're one of
the few people that tells the truth like
the American people feel and talk and
think on tell
telling the truth and I'm trying to say
the same thing in Congress but yet we're
the ones that are supposed to be for
Putin I don't think so you know who's
for China is the Biden Administration
and the idiots that I work with in
Congress that are leading us into World
War III and going to hurt America like
never before
there's a few things I want to bring up
right now
for a moment I thought his screen was
frozen but it turns out he was just like
and then as soon as he as soon as he
blinked I was like oh he's still alive
okay yeah he's known well he goes in a
bit but yeah I I think I think his I
think in his um in like his ear in his
earpiece they're probably like blink so
we know you're alive
you're not a mannequin blink right but
yeah it is uh not only that but the fact
that they find it funny to be like oh
they say though we're pro Putin you
literally want to stop funding Ukraine
from defending itself we are now I think
today is one year it's a one year
anniversary which would make sense why
she went on the show last night to
placate to this idea that uh
Putin's puppet on Putin's puppets
Network because remember Putin Putin you
know was under the impression that he
could dominate Ukraine within 12 hours
it has been 12 months 12 hours it has
been 12 months and Putin is weaker and
weaker by the day maybe
of the week
I'm just saying I mean I mean look I
think there's other opportunities the
guy is you know he's twitching his feet
and his hands and stuff and a lot of
people think he has like some conditions
like he's got Parkinson's or Hudson oh
he's a lunatic for sure oh yeah yeah
he's a Luna he's got a condition baby
and it's lunacy he is out of his mind
yeah you've got people like Margie
Taylor green being like Tucker Carlson
you're one of the only people that tells
the truth to the American people did we
not just find in legal documents from a
case of dominion versus Fox News that
showed Fox News and their emails and
their text messages that revealed oh it
actually turns out that Fox News was
trying to push this Division and play to
the idea that is like was there or was
there not voter fraud we're gonna say
there was voter fraud but we're not
going to totally Buy in because the
people who are totally bought in they
kicked out the people who rejected the
idea they kicked out but the people like
Tucker Carlson Sean Hannity Laura
Ingraham all of those people who flirted
with this will they won't they did they
didn't they kind of idea around election
fraud got got platformed to a bigger
slot to to a bigger audience to be the
front-facing people the post literally
the poster children
because after they are they're just kids
on the fox building right that's what
they got as as a way of
working for Murdoch and doing what
Murdoch wanted and so well here is here
is a one minute clip of last night well
a little over one minute but we'll watch
a little bit of it decoding Fox News put
this together you I I'll just show you
the clip of his anti-ukraine and pro
dictator I mean Pro Putin yeah rhetoric
here and you just decide you tell me 85
year old Tycoon marries a stripper
unfortunately what happens to men also
tends to happen to the systems they
create scolded the Chinese government
like a tardy servant Shape Up China will
send you back to the seller we're gonna
tell them what the rules are
stop it you naughty Chinese stop it
here's Joe Biden once again playing
Churchill to Putin's Hitler
then without Fanfare or even official
notice the goal changed and became
ticking the Russian Port of Crimea just
because it'd be nice to have that always
wanted it want to take it now oh my God
then the goal became overthrowing Putin
and putting American tanks in Red Square
because sure we could manage Russia once
we overthrow the dictator we're good at
that we did it in Iraq we did it in
Libya now the objective appears to be
winning World War III against both
Russia and China a war that would by
definition include the use of nuclear
weapons and the deaths by incineration
of hundreds of millions of people and
then once you add a thousand other off
the book sources of Aid the entire Intel
world you're looking at perhaps 200
billion dollars to zielinski and his
wife in 12 months you wouldn't have a
Cartel War in Texas and Arizona which
we're absolutely going to get that we
should send the contents of the U.S
treasury to a corrupt Eastern European
country to facilitate World War III
a framed poster of Putin bare-chested on
a on a horse in your office you know
what I'm gonna pull I'm gonna pull that
photo up for everyone yeah why I give um
Tucker his dishonorable mention one more
time we're not put inside oh my God man
what a [__] scumbag look at him he's
so happy too that he's Putin's puppet
show me happy he's so happy
that I mean dude I'm not saying
this is official but it looks pretty
official to me oh yeah are we spending
conspiracy theories here because I mean
if I don't know if anyone's got an
inside looking to Tucker Carlson's uh
office but look at his photos let's see
it says that no one should be surprised
that Tucker Carlson loves Vladimir Putin
the writing is on the wall you posted
this picture so it's got to be real look
it's him on him on a horse him in a
bathing sauna pool him fishing
him
wrestling with a small child because I
love children that's weird
Tucker you're weird dude and you're the
dishonorable mention of the week thank
you very much uh for being such a
scumbag so he can put you as disanimal
mention of the week
ah Tucker you [__]
you know uh one of the best George
Carlin
quotes ever is [__] Tucker Tucker sucks
like just that and he knew long before
any of us the Tucker sucked um speaking
of someone else who sucked you know who
won bone end of the week it's not a big
surprise she's undefeated in the actual
bonehead poll she's never she has never
been defeated
March Madness is coming up bone head mad
new yeah not not at all uh not at all
associated with March Madness which we
would get in trouble if we would say
March Madness if it was Associated but
it's not associated right but also I
can't say that it's not associated I
said on the show that if
if she won I would rename it to Marge
Madness for this year but right I think
she didn't win no she didn't win she
lost in a bracket that's the only time
she's lost on bonehead uh a poll but the
actual bone of the week pole she is
undefeated she has never lost
a bone end of the week pull and this
week it is no surprise because how many
weeks ago was it that she said that a
school in Illinois got five billion
dollars
one bit was it three three weeks ago
yeah Margarita I'm sorry I had to look
it up Margin Taylor green lost
to Ron DeSantis really yeah huh that's
interesting anyway I'm excited for 2023
bonehead midnight is right so we're
gonna have that coming up so you guys
can vote for all that um all that the
the madness not March Madness because we
cannot take that let's call it Mars we
can't call uh March Madness we could if
she wins call it Marge Madness I think
anyway get away with it Marge Marge yeah
enunciate the G
Madness but the reason why she became
the bonehead
um this I mean just one reason wow right
but it is that Marge don't math
Marge doesn't math that's the I we made
it the math ain't math and man I'll tell
you it just she just doesn't know how to
math at all
um so this is the Tweet the Gathering on
the bonehead this week uh it was the
five billion dollars that a school
received in elementary school is a
really bone-headed math move buyer
here's what she says 113 billion has
been appropriated to Ukraine in just one
year oh my God okay that 113 billion all
right she's got a number there she's
knowing numbers she didn't know what to
do with him but she's got one and she
says Trump's wall would have cost only
22 billion but Congress refused to fund
it okay so she's got another number 22
billion all right all right so she's
she's throwing out numbers here let's
see this last number she throws out
six billion people illegally crossed
over the Border since Biden took office
but Ukraine's water is the only border
That Matters to Washington six billion
people does she know how many people are
in this country does she have any idea
how many let's just Google the exact
number how many million people no how
many billions of people are how many
United States yeah how many billions
billions of people are in the United
States not in the world are in the
United States it's got to be well over
six because if six billion people have
crossed over the borders no Tony oh it's
not how much how many is it it's uh man
I'm sorry to tell you this man it's not
even close to a billion
uh it's uh
336 million wait 126
223 people as of Friday today now now
listen listen I'm just saying dude
Google has to be wrong it has to be 336
billion people there is no way that's
that Gabe if you think about this and
you use I don't know like just your
logic here think about this if six if
six billion people crossed over the
Border there couldn't be less than six
billion people
in the United States right now well I
mean you know what here this is look all
I'm going to say is this math is a
little too above my pay grade well did
you get your scientific get your
scientific
Tesla truck turkey later out look look
what I'm doing is I'm gonna go to chat
GPT and I'm gonna ask the AI how many
billions of people yeah are in the
United States okay let's see what it
says let's see what chant that libtard
chat GPS spits out what does it say it
says as of my knowledge cutoff date of
September 2021 okay the estimated
population of the United States was
approximately 331 million people which
according to Google it said or the
worldometer it said it was actually much
higher than that it was 336 million
people
ah it says it is important to note that
this is not in the billions but rather
in the hundreds of millions oh my God oh
God this is this woke chat GPT is trying
to suppress the numbers it just doesn't
know that there's 336 billion people how
in the [__] how because I know what she
did here
I know what she did here she was on this
billion number right she's like oh yeah
we're gonna get him with the word
billions billions billions because we
gave 113 billion dollars to Ukraine
we're gonna show those [__] libtards
what billions are like what the [__]
this woman ran a construction business
oh my God no no her husband ran it
her husband she inherited she inherited
this woman run a a CrossFit gym no she
just [__] the guy ran it for her got
it okay okay she just ran the guy This
Woman's on a committee she is now on a
committee unfortunately unfortunately
she is now on a community okay I got a
[__] I'm gonna have to I'm gonna
have to use this I don't know I don't
know if this is made up before this but
this is a new term that I'm going to use
in a video at some point
meganomics
you know we I was I was thinking this
whole time what which clip are we gonna
post on Midas Touch and now that
meganomics has made it hell how can we
not put this on there oh the meganomics
of Marjorie Taylor the petty Yeti
hookfoot green uh you are the professor
of magonomics at Trump University an
undefeated bonehead of the week let's
give her her do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
Marge he doesn't know math Marge don't
know math but she knows her some
magnanomics Baby Bam Shakalaka I heard
that Margaret Taylor green got a Noble
Peace Prize oh really work in maganomics
right did the cable give it to her uh
yeah well actually the gazpacho police
delivered it too oh okay yeah
oh so the meganomics and megabonics
um
megabonics and meganomics holy actual
[__] oh never fails here at the Tony
Michaels podcast and it never fails on
bone out of the week because their
boneheads every [__] week it never
fails and we break it down every Friday
you vote you decide and you see it here
on the second hour of the Tony Michaels
podcast and a clip on the Midas touch
Network do not forget to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast watch every
single episode every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific Live on YouTube I know
you're on YouTube right now I know
you're watching this hit the Subscribe
button come on over search the Tony
Michaels podcast also you can vote there
on YouTube Gabe Sanchez you just go to
the community Tab and as long as our
moderators hole is accountable we'll put
we'll put the we'll put the bowl up
there on you know you are we'll put the
poll up there on you YouTube will also
put it up on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod those are the two places you can
vote on Twitter and on YouTube do not
forget to subscribe each place it is
free the other thing that's free Gabe
Sanchez is you can download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast on
Apple's Spotify and Google
absolutely free no cost to you those
aren't meganomics those are real nomics
those are real nomics there that I'm
giving you my TV's going crazy in the
back what is going on over there it's
it's probably timed out we've been we've
been on the air for a while now dude my
graphic time it's the yeah it doesn't
know it doesn't know how to it's not a
is that that's is that a is that a mega
timer it is a mega timer it's a magazine
that's got magic every second is a
little bit off like by a fraction right
right well I thought you said it to six
billion seconds I did I did yeah well
maybe it was maybe it was six katrillion
um or past that point we're past that
point so do not forget to go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.dtonymichaels.com you can see this
one is the Rhonda Santos can go [__]
himself since Rhonda Santas actually
beat Marjorie Taylor green in a bracket
on on Marge Madness and bonehead Madness
as it's known now but we'll be having
that soon because the March the mark the
month of March is coming up very soon
yeah because we do bonehead every single
week every Friday right here and thank
you Marjorie Taylor green for
participating and being our winner this
week on bonehead of the week if you're
on the live broadcast stick around
we have a few announcements for you
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh yeah my TV went crazy see
that you can still see the graphic yeah
yeah it's a little bit smaller it's like
a you know a little shrinkage right
shrinkage it's like a trump size
um it's
it it's just a slide that I pull up on
the TV and at time down so yeah you know
it's live TV or live radio or live
whatever streaming whatever you want
it's live so it's live it [__]
happens uh what a great bonehead of the
week meganomics holy [__] never fails on
economics like I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm going to put this in a video I
don't know if it's gonna be a sketch or
if it'll make it on a what was that but
who knows one of those two it will be
and maybe both yeah I love it a good
phrase I used to use to describe the
neuron covid was spread necks oh yes and
I made a video about it I don't know if
I was the first to it but um Rick Wilson
of Lincoln project stole it as soon as
he saw it I know he did no he did well
you know you and me both there's a
tendency of projects uh yeah
content yeah happens it happens
but you know what you can watch our
content two hours a day every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on YouTube and you
should subscribe we're trying to get to
20 000 we're over 14 now
wow way you also follow us on Twitter at
the Tony Michaels pod download every
single episode on Apple Spotify Google
go over to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
check out the new what was that and all
the extras you can get over there why
you're on patreon do not forget to visit
my page check mine out the Tony Michaels
patreon.comichles.com also follow
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
watch us on the upwire.com just go there
you can go to their YouTube channel and
on Twitch this is very important it's
very important Gabe Sanchez this is a
free way to support us monetarily it
doesn't cost the audience anything to
support us monetarily this way if you
have an Amazon Prime account okay and
you go and you download the Twitch app
and you log in with your Amazon Prime
account you get one free subscription it
doesn't cost you a thing free it doesn't
cost you a thing as long as you've got
an Amazon Prime account you get one free
subscription all you have to do is give
us that subscription and it gives us
it's like three dollars a month it's
nice it's really not a lot but if we get
a lot of people to do it it'll maybe get
us to three hours a day I'm just saying
and those you want three hours a day you
gotta Prime again you want to give us
your subscription
it's free for you to give us that
monetary support doesn't cost you a
nickel doesn't just doesn't really just
love great look at now now when all oh
oh now it's on now it's on a screensaver
oh wait I I might have Hunter Biden's
[__] on this screensaver I might it
would be funny if you did have a bunch
of landscape stuff and then just a dick
just a dick this is a huge a picture of
Hunter Biden's hog you're like is that a
whale no that's a dick no that's a coked
up dick oh my God no I that's not what I
don't have that sort of thing on my um I
don't have that sort of thing on my on
my uh what is that screensaver is that
what it's called it's fine you can have
a public one and a private one for sure
oh can you really yeah you can stream
whatever you want to that screen
should I start playing PornHub in the
background is that what you're saying
Jesus Christ it's Friday I think we
should play videos of porn that are
right up until the point of them doing
it oh okay okay it's like all of the
lead up of terrible acting right right
and like forced kind of uh dialogue and
then it's like oh as soon as they
start to do it or they're taking the
clothes off they're like nope switch to
the next one look at this and we're only
17 minutes for the three we always go
over with bone in the week Pam it's not
there's nothing I can do nothing to see
now my TV
has the shortest attention space right
it was like I was talking we're talking
[__] over here and he's like all right
that's it I'm done you guys are taking
the day off I'm taking the day off [__]
you [__] you I mean you didn't even get
that screensaver on there for like two
minutes it was like a minute it was like
no we're done now we're gonna go into
this I'm done mode and now it's gonna go
into the if you don't touch me I'm
turning off in two minutes the TV's
gonna turn off probably uh before we
head out uh Robbie also says I'm gonna
forward you my Soros chest blessings
blessings we haven't been getting our
Soros checks for a while I think it's
because I talk [__] about tyt and
Pac-Man you know they're they're Soros
funded I saw a video the other day of
David Pacman and I was like yeah man
this is boring it's boring
I don't know how to I don't know how to
describe it it was it was a very like
non-take on something it was reporting
the news but it also wasn't really
reporting the news I don't know he's so
boring he's so boring and let me tell
you one reason why he's boring is
because he actually is syndicated so he
has to be boring because he has yeah and
he uh he's got another guy that does
like other videos on the channel too
right but yeah he's he's syndicated so
you know whatever
syndicated can't say the word [__]
that's why uh Leslie points out a really
because I was tired of Lacey Lacey
excuse me yeah Lacy Carter um she she um
she points out a good point about the
twitch thing because you get a free
subscription right yeah but you do it
every month so she says which is my how
month is over so you can like you can go
back and forth like if you have three or
four people you want to support with
your Prime
um with your Prime subscription on
Twitch you can do that each month you
can like give it to one person and give
it to the other and it doesn't again
it's not a lot of money but it adds up
if a lot of you do it yeah I think we've
got I don't know 25 or 30 people that go
over there so it's not a lot of money
but it helps it helps out and it really
honestly because this is our job like
this is what we do and we don't make any
money doing this show because it's free
it is free for you guys to watch so when
you support us on patreon whether it's
mine or it's Gabe's whether you go to
the merch store that that gives us
monetary support where you go to Twitch
that doesn't cost you a thing that's I I
actually like that now that we have that
because it doesn't cost you anything if
you have a Prime account which a lot of
people do yeah I got a Prime account
that's right and it gives us money are
you did you sign up for the I don't know
if I did ah you need to yeah you need to
give the subscription but but anyways
listen it's not just monetary support
that keeps us going too because the
wider our audience gets the more people
will want to give that support in some
form or fashion so if you share the
videos follow us on Twitter retweet
stuff share the link to the show
whatever you do come to the YouTube
channel and like every all the episodes
watch the episodes in full the other
thing you can do is go down even though
you watch the episodes Go download the
audio version listen to you know five
ten minutes and and you can listen into
twice the speed on there and then that
gives us support so there's a lot of
ways to do it and you guys are the best
audience in the world it doesn't matter
if you're on our patreon or you're just
here chatting every day we appreciate
everything that you do for this show
because without you we wouldn't have it
we would not be sitting here talking
without you guys so that is the most
important thing to us so anything you
new to support our show because it it is
it is what we do it is exactly what we
do and I'm excited to see this new what
was that from for uh George I think
everyone would get a good laugh uh I
mean I think here's the thing I have for
those of you who are still listening
uh I have George Santos's cell phone
number
oh so I'm gonna text him the video and
I'm gonna say hey
what do you think
amen and I know can you watch this can
you tell me what this hey man can you
I'm gonna and no joke give me a like on
this video
uh I do have a cell phone number I have
called him I have spoken to him I have
texted with him oh man
um so I will text him the video and I
will ask and be like hey
what do you think you like because I
call out he he in this video in this
interview that he does with um with
Pierce Morgan
he he doubles down on the lies by lying
New Lies
for the old lies
so like he he makes new things like he
says like oh like I wasn't I wasn't I
wasn't the main guy at my friends of
pets you know so he makes up new lies to
cover up your life this seems this I I I
I I gotta say this seems very Republican
yeah it is she's very robust just that
make up a new lie it's very trumpian
it's almost like there's a magnet it's
almost like magnomics oh yeah involved
in how many lines they can tell like
they're
dematria maganomics uh you know the
whole the whole inner web of doing the
science in a peach tree dish you know
the whole thing right
it is just one of those things where you
would say why do you keep talking why
are you doing interviews I mean
obviously because he's a [__]
sociopath and he's a narcissist and he
has to have attention on him and I
actually break that down at the very end
of the video where I talk about why
George Santos has made certain lies
especially after the 2020 election
well he is a [__] box and it's not a
surprise because he is a Republican and
if you're wondering why he's still doing
interviews it's because he is a
narcissist because he's a Republican and
he only cares about one thing and that's
the attention that is given to him
because they're greedy bastards yeah and
I hate to break it to you but he's
probably not going to win his race uh
he'll run but he's probably not going to
win his race in the primary
um but he's going to try but he wants to
get as much attention as he possibly can
until he gets indicted and gets put in
prison right well the thing is he had to
he had to announce a new Treasurer I
don't know if people know this but he
had to do it he had to announce a new
Treasurer because the one that he had
resigned most likely because they're
under investigation then he uh uh
falsely announced that it was Thomas
Detweiler right and tell me he was like
I don't I'm I don't know I'm not
associated with this people on you at
all like not at all and now he's got a
new person who's like this unknown dude
who is now the treasure because the FEC
said hey you have to now or the uh
forget which one I think it was FEC uh
uh right Federal yeah Federal elections
committee yeah they were like you have
to announce who your Treasurer is
especially you also have to announce if
you're gonna run again once your term is
over because he raised a there's a
there's a minimum amount of money that
if your campaign raises it after you've
been in office then you have to and I
think it's 5 000 or something like that
you have to announce that you uh whether
or not you have to announce your intent
on whether you do want to run for office
or you do not want to run for office and
so I think he's got like two weeks and I
think that's coming up real soon they're
getting really easy here they're lying
ads how funny would it be if we closed
out with two minutes listen dude we
could do three hours I could do six
hours of this [__] every day and not run
out of material to mock these people
right that is how much [__] we don't
make it on the show like literally I go
back and I look at stuff I'm like damn
it we didn't talk about that damn it we
didn't talk about that and I'm like
maybe I'll talk about it tomorrow but by
the time I get there I'm like there's
six other things now I can't go back I
mean it's the same thing like working on
them what the hell am I gonna do what
was that I'm like uh hey uh I'm working
on this and then something else develops
I'm like ah [__] that's even better and
I'm like still trying to simultaneously
run this older thing you know yeah
that's crazy it's crazy should we cut it
out before we get to three hours because
if we go to three hours they're gonna be
like three hours every day we know you
can do it we know you could we could do
it every day we could every day but the
reason why we're here for two hours is
because of you and everyone have a great
weekend be safe be safe this weekend I
hope you have a great one I hope you eat
a lot of great food I hope you drink
some booze and watch some porn maybe I
don't know if you're into that sort of
thing you know hey support your
favorites out there that's right that's
right
go like and share those content creators
as well
hey we'll see the same time same place
on Monday Surfside [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon